foreign
ly we have reached the last day of
software development week offered by
simply not this week has been an amazing
journey of learning the software
development process we started right
from the building blocks the data
structures and algorithms then started
off with C plus plus then we landed on
Java and obtained a comfortable
understanding of core and advanced Java
Concepts later we learned the Python
programming language and now here we are
at our last stop Javascript JavaScript
is rigorously used for multiple purposes
whether it is a mobile application or a
desktop application or a website all you
need is Javascript it is also recognized
as one of the most popular and highly
used programming languages in the
current ID industry this session is
dedicated in helping Learners to get
acquainted with the JavaScript
programming language now without any
further Ado let's get over to our
experts
we'll Begin by understanding what
exactly JavaScript is and then we'll
understand the learning path to
JavaScript
followed by which we'll see tutorials on
Concepts like creating your first
JavaScript program using hello world
then we'll move on to more technical
topics like arrays Loops objects this
keyword functions
form validation regular expressions and
email validation moving ahead we'll look
at asynchronous programming Concepts
like promises and async await we'll also
look at a detailed tutorial on Dom and
finally coming to the most awaited part
to develop five different projects using
JavaScript
and lastly we'll end the session by
looking at the top interview questions
in JavaScript so I hope you're excited
for it so without further delay let's
Jump Right In first let's have a look at
a brief history of JavaScript
JavaScript Was Written In 10 Days by
Brendan Ike in 1995. he was working at
Netscape at the time and was
implementing Java the hot buzzword for
the browser later he developed a more
easy to use programming language called
MoCA the idea was to make Java available
for big professional component writers
while mocha would be used for small
scripting tasks
mocha was later renamed to JavaScript
now in 2009 node.js was released this
allowed programmers to write full
applications in JavaScript npm was also
created for installing reusable bits of
code in libraries
so moving on what exactly is Javascript
JavaScript is a server-side and
client-side programming language it is
commonly used to create web applications
now all of these applications in
JavaScript can be seen in diverse Fields
like gaming web development server
development robotics among others
popular JavaScript libraries and
Frameworks like react.js and angular
have scaled tremendously in the past few
years let's begin with JavaScript
fundamentals I'm sure these are topics
that everybody has already learned
however getting a fundamental strong
lays the foundation for better and
faster learning
some of these include the lexical
structure of JavaScript
JavaScript variables types and
expressions
JavaScript functions which include the
function Constructor self-invoking
functions functions as values and
objects Arrow functions generator
functions and predefined functions
then there's JavaScript arrays it could
be array methods mapreduce and filter
then there's JavaScript Loops which
include the for Loop for in Loop while
loop and the two while loop and then we
have objects which include creating
objects object properties methods and
accessors
moving on there is data structures like
Boolean string number null undefined
this control flow statements like if
else
there's data object there's type
conversions that is converting from one
data type to another
then there's mathematical operators and
lastly there's scope in JavaScript that
talk about the local and Global
variables
now once you've laid your foundation
strong you can go ahead and work on more
advanced topics
now let's have a look at them
first one being callbacks now this is a
pillar for something called as
asynchronous programming
and then there's promises and finally
there's async a weight that I built on
cheap asynchronous programming
there's closures there are an extension
of variable scope and Define how Global
and local variables are accessed now
help in delaying the execution of
certain code or functions
then there's prototyping followed by
inheritance now they specify how
JavaScript objects and methods from a
prototype
next up there's binding
there's also regular Expressions where
you'll have to learn about Flags
patterns quantifiers meta characters and
basic string search and replacement
techniques
lastly we have Unicode event Loops which
involve blocking an event creating a
simple event
and moving on let's look at some of the
important web platform tools required to
master JavaScript
first up we have cookies that talk about
how to create read change and delete
cookies for any web browser there's
local storage that is you'll have to
know how data is being stored locally in
the browser
we have apis or application programming
interfaces that Define how to extend
functionalities to a browser one such
important API is the fetch API which is
important to request resources be it
network is the document object model
that defines how anything that is being
changed on the browser is affecting the
model State and vice versa
and lastly we have service worker which
is basically a script that runs in the
background of a web browser offline app
development
moving on let's have a look at the tools
script now JavaScript offers a wide
range of these libraries and Frameworks
however you could choose to learn
whichever that suits your interests and
requirements
firstly there's react which is an
excellent JavaScript front-end library
that helps create interactive web pages
now there's angular which is a
JavaScript frame next up we have view
which is also a front-end JavaScript
framework used to create single page
applications now although these
libraries and Frameworks have the same
objectives their underlying architecture
and working differ and as a result of
this different people prefer different
Frameworks and libraries for app
development your Kickstart is typescript
now typescript basically defines a set
of types to JavaScript and helps users
write JavaScript code that is easier to
understand
typically all the typescript code
compiles down to JavaScript code
next for simple overview of what we've
learned we have beginner level or
fundamental topics then we have the
advanced level topics there's web
platform and finally there's tools
but you must be wondering how can we
help you now one thing you could do is
take up a simple learn certification
course
to help you understand this better let
me just open JavaScript
foreign
that we provide you have the node.js
training course and then there's the
full stack and object oriented
now the best part about JavaScript is
the fact that it's open source and it's
across platform compatible meaning one
piece of code written in any system
regardless of the operating system
functions the same in other operating
systems as well
lastly most commonly used as a part of
web pages that allows client-side script
to interact with the user and make
Dynamic pages
now moving on to the next important
question why JavaScript
now being the most popular language in
the world JavaScript has a huge fan base
and benefits from a large community
support
JavaScript is now being used in many
industry Fields such as web development
mobile application development and also
game development it is very diverse in
nature
there are great career opportunities for
JavaScript developers as this technology
seems to be holding on its own when
compared to other languages
all right now moving on let's go ahead
and execute it simple program to
understand JavaScript better
so we'll go ahead and execute a simple
hello world program
all right for that first thing you need
is a text editor in this case we've used
the VF code editor
so now let's go to our text editor that
is vs code and here let's open a file so
say in file and now you can type in your
code here so we will have to add the
JavaScript to the HTML code and then
print out the words hello world on the
browser window right that's an objective
so let's add the HTML boilerplate in
this file
so let's type in HTML
this is our tag
and then next we have the body type
So within the body tag
you can add the script tag to insert the
JavaScript into HTML page right so we
say script
language
equals JavaScript
and type
equals
text
slash
JavaScript
all right
let's close the path
and then in the script we call a
JavaScript function that is document.wi
which writes the string to our HTML page
right so we say document
dot right
and within braces we say hello world
okay and now we close the tags
we also close the body
and primary
all right
now when we save the file
we're going to save it say on my desktop
and I'm going to call it index dot HTML
right so make sure the extension is HTML
and then save it
already exists
as I replace it
and now once you save it as an HTML file
you can see that the colors will appear
so any errors will be easily indicated
here
so now let me save this and now let's go
ahead and execute the file that is
stored
okay let me go back
to my desktop
and here I have indexed HTML there you
go when you click on the file it opens
in your browser
and you can see the words hello world
in this video we will be learning all
about JavaScript arrays and the popular
methods of the array object
so what exactly is an array
now an array object lets you store
multiple values in a single variable
it stores a fixed size sequential
collection of elements of the same type
now when array is used to store a
collection of data and it uses only
integers as element indices
however associative arrays can also use
string indices
moving on let's understand what array
operations are
now we can perform various operations on
an array in JavaScript
but let's start by creating an array
so for that let's go ahead and create a
folder first which will consist of the
file that we're creating right so for
that
let me just uh go ahead and create a
folder
and I'll call it demo underscore array
so once you're done with that open your
Visual Studio code editor
and here say open folder
and click on demo array
okay is creating the workbench all right
and now here you can see the new file
icon so go ahead and create
demo.html file
all right here you go now let's start
typing the code
the first thing we do is type in our
HTML tag
and here I have the head tag
[Music]
foreign
JavaScript
tutorial
all right and now let's create the body
tag
now within the body tag I create a
paragraph tag and create an ID
and let me call it demo
and then close the tag now I'll explain
to you why we're doing this a little
later
so first let's go ahead and create the
script tag
so say script
and within the script let's create our
array so let me use the keyword let
and say we give the name of direct cars
equals in square based braces we say BMW
and Volvo
[Music]
and then say Honda
all right so now we create an array now
one more thing is that we use the
keyword let so that which indicates that
the array can be changed throughout the
program
all right so now we go ahead and display
it so I say document
[Music]
dot get element by ID
and here I say now the ID created was
demos so I say demo here
and I use the DOT in our HTML property
which is equal to cars
okay let me change this to BMW first
all right so what exactly a naught HTML
does is that it is responsible for what
is being displayed on the web page okay
now since we've taken ID as demo any
changes made is reflected in this ID and
then displayed onto the web browser
all right so let's save this and now
execute the file
so here I go back to my folder and then
the file and go ahead and click on it
so there you go
The Heading is displayed and the entire
array is displayed here
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
okay so I hope this was easy to
understand
now let's go ahead
so the next operation is to access an
array element
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let's create another variable
say let BMW BMW variable don't get
confused with the array element
so BMW equals cars of the index 0. so
basically cars of 0 is nothing but BMW
all right so that is being saved in the
variable BMW
and now let's just go ahead and display
this
so we let's just copy this
and paste it here and instead of cars
you use the variable name BMW that is
this one
all right
so now let's save this
and when we
execute it
you see BMW here that's how you retrieve
an element from an array next up we have
the array length property which displays
the length of the array
so again let me show you how to do that
let's go back to our code
and here let's create a variable and
let's call it length variable so I say
let Len
equals cars.lab
now you can use the length property
which will retrieve the length of the
array for us it's as simple as that
and now after this again let's just
copy the same
code here and then
let's pass length okay
now let's save this
and when you execute it again
it says 3.
so we've successfully retrieved the
length of the array
all right so the next operation is to
access the last array element right so
let's go back to our vs code and now
let's create another variable and let's
call it last
and we'll just say last equals cars
and within Square braces cars.length
minus 1.
right
so basically
the length of the array is 3 and 3 minus
1 is 2 so it should retrieve
cars of 2 which is Honda right
so let's just
execute this and we pass last here
save it and see if it displays Honda
operas
there you go
it's as simple as that
all right so moving on
the next array operation is Loop over an
array item
so for that let's go to our
code
and here
let's use the for load so I say cars dot
for each
and within this we'll save
item
comma index
comma array
and now we use the arrow function
and display the content on the console
so I say console.log
of item
along with its index
so let's see this
and now let's go ahead and execute it
all right now as you can see nothing is
printed on your web page right because
whatever is being printed has to be
printed in your console so now click on
F12 which opens the developer options
and here you can see console so click on
that and now you can see the name of the
item in the array along with its index
so you see BMW 0 Volvo 1 and Honda two
all right
so moving on now that we've learned
about the array operations let's go
ahead and learn about the array methods
so the first method is to string now as
the name suggests it is used to convert
an array into a string
all right so let's go back to our vs
code
and now let's copy the same
code here
and here instead of last I just save
cars dot to string
now you can use this method
to convert the array into a string so
let's save this
and let's execute it
all right now here are the same output
as shown which means that the type has
only been changed to string type
All Right Moving On the next method is
pop now pop basically removes the last
element from the array so let me show
you how that works
let's go back to our vs code and here
we have to save the pop element into a
variable right so let's create a
variable say last
okay and oh since last is already used
let me call it last one
last one of cars.pop and we can use the
pop method to pop the element
and now you can just copy the same code
to display this onto our web page
and here
I just say
last one
now
since we've popped the last element the
array has only two elements right that
is BMW and Volvo so if you want to
display the last element it should
display Volvo right so what we can do is
we can just create another variable say
last two
and just use the same logic here
okay and now let's just
display it on your console and let's say
last two all right
so now let's save it
now the popped element has been saved in
last one which is displayed on the web
page and the last element of the array
after the pop function has to be
displayed on our console so let's go
ahead and execute the file
all right so Honda has been displayed
that is the element that has been
removed from the array and now once we
check our console
here you go here you can see Volvo which
means that is the last element in the
array
moving on
the next method is the push method now
as the name suggests it is used to add a
new element to the array and remember to
the end of the array so let's go back to
our vs code
and here let me say cars
dot push push is the method that we're
using
inside of which we'll say Audi all right
and now let's just display the same
things so let me copy this
and here let me say cars
okay so let me save it
and once I execute it
it says BMW Volvo and Audi so we'll
successfully added another element to
the end of the array
so the next method is the shift method
now basically shift is used to remove
the first element from the array now
this method shifts all the elements
reducing the indices of every element by
one all right let me show you how this
works
so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just say cars dot shift
it's as simple as that and let's just
display this
let me copy the same thing
let's save it
and when we execute it
here you can see it just displays Volvo
and Audi so now cars has array elements
Volvo and Audi with array indices 0 and
1.
all right so moving on the next method
is on shift
all right so to add an element into the
beginning of an array we use the unshift
method therefore this method increases
the array index by one
right so let's go back to our vs code
and use the same function on shift
let's say cars.unship
and here we go let's
save it and here we have to specify what
we're adding right let me see Hyundai
okay
let's save this
and when we execute it you can see
Hyundai Volvo and Ori
it's as simple as that
all right moving on the next method is
the concat method now this is basically
used to merge two different areas right
so let's go back to our vs code
Ensure
let's create another array first
and let's just call the array bikes okay
and let's create say Yamaha
and let's see Suzuki
[Music]
and then we'll say Royal Enfield
and now
let's save this
and say let Vehicles this is another
array which is basically the after
concatenation
the entire array is saved into this
array all right so let's say cars Dot
concat
[Music]
of bikes we just can't get bikes and
cars together
okay and then let's just
display this over the web page so
let me change this to vehicles
[Music]
all right let me save this
so let's go ahead and execute it
there you go now both the areas have
been merged together into a single array
so the next array method is the sort
method now basically sort is used to
sort the entire array into ascending
order all right so let's go back to our
editor
and here
let's just use the
sort method on the
array Vehicles all right
Vehicles dot sort
okay and
let's just
display this on our web page
so again
let's go back and
execute it and here you can see it has
been sorted
the next method
is the reverse method so the reverse
method is again used to reverse the
elements in an array so it's logic right
so sort was used to sort it in ascending
order now when you reverse it it just
sorts it in the descending order
so let's go back here
you want to copy the same thing
all right and here instead of sort
let me just say reverse
this and execute it
there we go it is displayed the entire
array in the reverse order
all right
with that we finish the array methods
next up we have map reduce and filter
first up we have array.map now the map
method is used for creating a new array
from an existing one by applying a
function to each and every one of the
elements in the first array
and it does not change the original
array all right so to make you
understand this better let's go back to
our Visual Studio code
and now here let's first create another
area
okay so let me call this num1
and let's have
integers let's say 2 3 4 5.
6 and 7. okay
and now let's have another array
num2
so let's go ahead and say num1
dot map
of let me Define a function say multiply
okay
so multiply is the function that is that
I am going to Define here
so let's say function
multiply
of value
okay
and inside this let me say return
value
into two
okay
so what this basically does
is that it multiplies each and every
element of the array num1 by 2 and saves
the new elements into the array num2
okay now after this let's go ahead and
display the contents so let me copy this
and let's display the content in the
array nump2
right so let me save it
let's go back here
execute it so there we go every element
has been multiplied by two and then
displayed again
I hope this was clear for you
now the next method is the filter method
so the filter method takes each element
in an array and applies a conditional
statement against it
and if this condition returns true the
element gets pushed onto the output
array but if it returns false the
element does not get pushed all right so
let me show it to you
now let's
go ahead and create another
variable say num3
and here I see num1
dot filter
of say com now comp is a function let me
Define the function here
let me say function
comp
of value
takes a value as a parameter
within which I'm going to check if the
value is greater than 4.
now with only appends the element into
the array num3 if the value is greater
than 4. all right so now let me just
go ahead and change this to num3 all
right let's save this
and when we go back and execute
here we go
now the values so let's go back here let
me check
now num1 had the values 2 3 4 5 6 and 7
right so according to this it has to
only display it's five six and seven do
not get confused with num2 here we've
passed num1 here so it checks put this
array
right so according to the logic it
should display five six and seven and it
has done so here
okay
moving on
the next method is the reduce method
now the reduced method reduces an array
of values down to just one single value
now to get the output value it runs a
reducer function to each element of that
array
okay now this method does not reduce the
original array again
so let's go back to our vs code
now let me create another
variables in Num 4 and say num1 dot
reduce
and let me call it sum so what we're
basically doing is that we're adding all
the digits two three four five six and
seven in num1 to a single value right
that is the sum and then we're going to
be displaying that
so what we're going to do is let's
define the function here
function sum
basically is total comma value
right and then here let's say return
total Plus
the value
okay
and after this
I'm going to
display the content so let's say num 4.
okay let's save it go back and execute
here we go it displays the sum of the
entire values in the array
this was pretty simple right
now before jumping into the for Loop
let's first understand what exactly a
loop is right so a loop is basically a
programming construct that executes a
piece of code as long as a certain
condition is met
all right and there are two different
types of Loops we have entry control
loops and exit control groups now what
exactly are entry control loops now
these are the loops where the test
condition is checked before executing
the piece of code
for example you have the for Loop and
the while loop so in their case before
entering the loop the condition is
checked and only if the condition is met
it enters the loop and executes the code
all right when it comes to exit control
loops the test condition is checked
after the loop has been executed
all right so in this case the loop at
least gets executed I mean the code in
the loop gets executed at least once
so the example for this is a two while
loop all right with this basic knowledge
let's go ahead and learn about the
different loops
so the first Loop is the for Loop all
right so what exactly is a for Loop this
is the basic logic and the flowchart in
front of you so what exactly happens is
that say for example you want to print
the word looping say 10 times right so
what you can do is you can start and you
can have a for Loop which goes from 0 to
9.
and then you increase the number by one
every time you print the loop once it's
equal to 10 or even greater than 10 it
ends the loop right so let me help you
understand this better with an example
so let's go to our editor that is vs
code
here I've created a folder called demo
underscore Loops within which I've
created a file called for Loops all
right so now let's just write down our
initial code for HTML that is
HTML
and then I have a head tag
[Music]
within which I say JavaScript
loops
all right
now I have a body tag
[Music]
within which I give a heading for
clearer understanding let me have a
heading save
JavaScript
for loops
all right
let me just call it for Loop
now let's have the script tag
[Music]
within which
I'll have
a variable say X
and now we have the for Loop so we say
four
x equals 0
X less than
X plus plus
in which I save console DOT log of x
so basically
what happens is
now you have the first readable which is
called the counter variable now this
keeps track of how many times the code
is being executed
right and next I less than 5 is a
condition now the loop keeps executing
as long as the condition is met and
lastly the counter variable is
incremented and usually it's incremented
by one right so here we've done the same
thing
and inside the loop we print the value
of x
all right so let me save the file
and then execute it
all right it's printed JavaScript Loops
here let me just go back
okay my bad I missed out on the title
tag
so this has to be enclosed within the
title tag so let me just
change it here
now let's save this
let's go back and just refresh the page
and that is it so whatever is in the
title tag basically appears here all
right so now since we're printing the
value of x on our console we'll have to
inspect our element so let's go here
and here let's check on console
and here you can see all the values have
been printed from 0 to 4. all right now
this is a simple for Loop
so next up is a while loop
now the logic is similar to that of a
for Loop so first the condition is
checked and if the condition holds true
then the code is executed and if it is
false it terminates
all right so moving on let's understand
the general syntax
so here first you have the variable
whose value keeps changing
and then you have the ending condition
which is basically the maximum value a
variable can reach all right so let's go
back to our vs code
and here for better understanding let me
just change this to JavaScript while
loop
all right let's just
delete this and here let's initialize
the value of x to 1.
and now I say while X
less than or equal to 5
within braces I
say console.log
of x
and then I increment the value of x
all right so let me save this and let's
execute the file
all right so it says JavaScript while
loop and let's inspect and here in our
console it displays the values of x
all right so according to the logic
X is initially initialized to 1.
and the value gets executed once it
enters the while loop all right it's
incremented and then checked every time
until the value reaches
6 right and then it breaks from the loop
since the value does not hold true and
then it terminates
so this is a logic behind the while loop
next up is the two while loop now here
as you can see first the code is
executed and then the condition is
checked if the condition is true then
the code execution continues and if it
falls it's terminated all right so this
is an exit control Loop also in an exit
control Loop the code is executed at
least once so let's go back to our vs
code
and here
let me just delete this
now let's initialize X to say
15 all right
and now I use the do keyword within
which I write the code so first I'm
going to print the value of x
console DOT log of x
and then I increase my value
and here I mention my test condition
which is while X less than say 10.
all right so according to the logic
initially the value is X and once it
enters the loop here
it should print the value of x which is
15. all right and then it increments the
value but once it comes out of the loop
it checks with the condition
here the condition says less than 10 but
since X is not less than 10 it prints
the value X that is 15 and then
terminates all right so let's save this
and execute it
so let me execute this
and here
let's check
the console
so there we go it prints 15. so what it
does is that it prints the value 15
first and then checks the condition
now
let's go ahead and change the value of x
to save
5.
all right
so now it enters the loop and then it
prints the value of x and then
increments it and when it comes out of
the loop and checks the condition
as long as the value of x remains less
than 10 it prints it okay
so let's save this
go back here
and let's refresh the page
and here you can see the values five to
nine are printed so this is how the do
while loop works
moving on to the next concept breaking
out of a loop now as the name suggests
break is the keyword that is used to
break out a pillow now here is a simple
code for you
so according to the logic it prints the
values between 1 to 10. and see at the
value 5 you want to break out of the
loop you can simply use the keyword
break so let's go back to our vs code
and here let me just
make it simple
and Save
for x equals one
X less than or equal to 10
[Music]
it's increment it
and within the loop let's
display the value X
on the console and then we're going to
check for the condition if x equals 5.
all right
so if x equals 5 we break out of the
loop
so let's save the file and execute it
and there you go it's displayed the
values from 1 to 5.
so basically the code inside the for
Loop is executed and once the value of x
reaches 5 it breaks from the loop
simple right
all right so let's move on
next up we have skipping a loop cycle
all right so here
what exactly we do is we make use of a
keyword continue to skip a particular
Loop cycle
say in this case we have a for Loop
which displays the values of I ranging
from 1 to 10. however we want to skip
the cycle when it reaches the value 3 so
what we do is we make use of the keyword
continue here so basically it displays
one and two and skips the third cycle
and then directly displays four all
right so let me show you in our vs code
editor
here
let me just remove this and Save
if
x equals
5.
[Music]
I'm going to continue
all right
after which
I'm going to say console
DOT log f of x
so let me save this and then execute it
so here let me refresh the page
and there we go
as you can see it displays one two three
and four and the fifth cycle
is kept
all right and the rest of the digits are
displayed so that is how you can skip a
load I highly suggest you also practice
all of this and then play around with
loops to get a better understanding
so taking a step forward we're going to
learn about JavaScript objects in this
video
so without further Ado let's begin and
look at what's in store for us
so what is a JavaScript object
JavaScript is an object-oriented
programming language so everything in
Java is an object
a JavaScript object is like a real world
entity having State and behavior for
example a car now we can take a car as
an object it will have its state like
color and model it will also have
behaviors like accelerate and break
JavaScript is template based and we can
create objects without having the need
to create a class
generally object is accompanied by a
class that defines an object's
blueprints but JavaScript doesn't
require any class to be defined for
objects
moving on to the next concept
to create a JavaScript object now
basically there are three different ways
of creating a JavaScript object all
right so we look at them one by one
the first one is to use a literal to
create and Define a JavaScript object
so let's go to our vs code editor
now if you have any doubts regarding the
initial setup then I suggest you go
through the previous video that is
Javascript arrays to get you started
with it so here I've created a folder
called demo objects and now I'm going to
create a file
called create
underscore objects
dot HTML
all right
so we'll Begin by writing the initial
code
that is the head and the body so I say
HTML
[Music]
within this as create the head tag
and then I create a title tag
[Music]
and let's say
JavaScript
objects
then after the Head Start I'm going to
create a body tag
and let's create a heading and say
creating JavaScript
objects
okay
and now we create
an ID
all of this is explained in the previous
video I really suggest you go through
the video before and that you get a
clear picture
and then I say ID equals
say demo
and then I'm gonna close it
now the first method that we're going to
use to create an object is by using
object literals right so what we can do
is say script
within which I declare a variable
say
where student
now within the object we're going to
create three different properties now
this is basically like a dictionary it
has a property a key and then a value
okay so I say name property and let's
say
crisp
and then another property say age and
say 21.
and another property say
studies
and say maybe computer designs
[Music]
okay
so this is the syntax used to create an
object using an object literally
now after this what we're going to do is
we're going to display this right now we
want to display the message saying Chris
of age 21 studies computer science
so what we can do is say document dot
get element by ID
and the ID that we're going to pass is
demo
we say
inner HTML
equals
student dot name
which is Chris
after which we display the message
of the age
and then the age that is student dot h
atties
student Dot
studies
okay let's save this
and when we execute the file it says
Chris of the h21 studies computer
science
all right this is one of the ways in
which you can define an object
all right so moving on to the next way
of creating a JavaScript object it is to
use the new keyword now this is the most
traditional way of creating an object
right so let's go back to our vs code
let's create another script
within which we see
where student equals new
object
I'm sure everybody has learned the same
way the same syntax
so this is one of the ways after which
we can say student dot name equals Chris
again student dot age
equals 21
[Music]
and then student Dot
studies
equals computer science
[Music]
all right
now after this we again
display the message so let me just copy
this
all right
so let's save this
and run our code again
and there we go it displays the message
Chris of the h21 studies computer
science
all right this was the second method
used to create an object
all right so they're moving on to the
third method
it is to use an object Constructor to
create and Define a JavaScript object
so let's go back to our code editor
and here
[Music]
we Define a function so we say function
says start
with three parameters that is name age
and say
studies
okay and now within the function we use
the keyword this so we say this dot name
equals name
all right and we say this dot h
equals h
when I say this dot studies
equals studies
now what we do is that we can
create a variable and pass parameters to
the function so it says where
student
equals stud and within braces we say
comma 21
comma computer science
[Music]
all right so we've done passing the
parameters
after this
we're gonna copy the same
print message
here
[Music]
all right so let's save this and execute
our file
so let's refresh the web page
and there we go it still displays the
message place of the h21 studies
computer science so this was the third
method that can be used to create
objects
moving on to the next topic
object properties
now a JavaScript object is basically a
collection of unordered properties right
values associated with the JavaScript
object are called its properties
and properties can usually be added
updated or deleted excluding read-only
properties so now let's have a look at
the demo to help you understand this
better
so let me go back to my
vs code so this was where we left off
and this was how we created objects
right so now let me create another file
and let me call it
objects underscore properties
[Music]
email
now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna copy
the first piece of code here
all right let me just copy this into my
new file
and here as you can see student is the
object that we've created and name it
and studies are the three properties
now say we want to update the age all
right so what we can do is here we can
just say student
dot h
equals
let me change it to 24 all right
and let me save this and when we execute
the file that is object underscore
properties
you can see Chris of the age 24 so 21 is
updated to 24. so this is one of the
ways you can do it
or there's another method
you can just assign the property to a
variable and then display the variable
instead so what we can do is you can
just assign student.h to a property say
X
and here instead of displaying
student.age we can just say
all right so let's save this
and when we run it
it says 21 because we haven't updated
21 to 24 anywhere all right
so 21 Remains the Same
so another method we can use is we can
just say
x equals h
so we're directly assigning the property
to the variable
and here when I am displaying it I say
student of x
all right
so let me save this
and when you look at the web page
it still displays the same thing these
are different ways of accessing the
properties you can update them delete
them unless they read only
all right so let's move on to the next
concept object methods now basically a
JavaScript method is an action that can
be performed on the objects
so you'll understand better with the
help of the demo
so let's go back to our vs code and here
I've created another HTML file called
objects underscore methods all right so
let's let me just copy the initial code
paste it here and let's have the
enclosing tags as well
and HTML all right now here I declare
another tag that is the button tag so
we're going to be making this a button
here so I save button
ID equals click me so that is the action
that I'm going to
performing
and the message that is going to be
displayed on the button will be
okay
all right
so we're gonna see the usage of it a
little later
now let's go ahead and create an object
so I say script
[Music]
within which I create
the user object
so we're created using a object little
here and I declare the property name
as Chris again
and age
[Music]
okay
so let's close this
all right so the next thing I'm going to
do is I'm going to create a new function
that we will use as an object method
all right so I say function
and let's give the name say hi
okay
within the function we declare
we basically display a message so we're
going to say alert and hello
all right so this is going to be
displayed in a separate dialog box
so now once the Declaration is done
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
create another property basically say
user Dot
let's say message
and assign say hi to it
so basically what we're doing
is we're adding the previously created
method to a new property that is user
Dot message the message property all
right
so now I say
document dot get element by ID
is a demo
[Music]
and the message that I want is just
High plus the username all right
[Music]
so what we're going to do is we're going
to display the message hello
all right when the user clicks on the
button
so for that let's say
let's just copy this
[Music]
and here
instead of demo
right we're going to be passing the IDE
click me
as per this and the event is going to be
on click event
so here I say on click
after which I'm going to Simply pass
user Dot message
let me just delete this
all right so here I notice that I've
given an equal to sign I'm sorry it's a
colon
all right so let's save the file
and let's go ahead and execute it
all right so here you can see high crisp
being displayed and once we click on the
button
you can see an alert which says hello
all right
so now let's move on to the next concept
that is Java object accessors
now Getters and Setters allow defining
an object accessor all right to get the
value of a property in a JavaScript
object we use a getter and to set the
value of a property of a JavaScript
object we use a setup so let's go back
to our demo
and now let me create another file
and let's call it
object
accessors
and now again let me just
copy the first initial part
[Music]
all right so now let's go ahead and
create a new
object so let me say script
but then which I say where
and let's call it car all right
so let me define the properties say
model
and
the model let's say BMW
320d
and
another property say color and let's say
it's navy blue
and the last property say fuel type
[Music]
and let's see it's diesel
now what we can do is we can you make
use of the keyword get
to access the properties so I say get
and say fuel
within which I return
this dot fuel type
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's display it document Dot
get element by ID
demo dot inner HTML equals we say car
dot fuel
all right so now let's save it
and execute our file
here you go it retrieves diesel for us
now this is one of the ways of accessing
the properties
now to help you understand Setter let's
go ahead and create another
foreign
car again
now let's say the model
is
Audi A4
[Music]
color be bright
red
[Music]
and fuel type let's keep it blank
all right
now to set the value we use the set
keyword we say set fuel
the parameter is fuel
within which we say this dot you will
type
[Music]
equals fuel right
now let's set the value for the fuel
say car dot fuel
equals petrol
all right
now let's display the same
let me copy this
and what we want to display is the fuel
type right so here we say fuel type
so let's save this
and let's go ahead and execute the file
and there we go it retrieves petrol
so what it does is basically it assigns
the value petrol to the property fuel
type and then we display the same on our
web page
so this is how you make use of Getters
and setters
so you must have heard about this
keyword several times so in JavaScript
this keyword basically refers to an
object which is executing the current
piece of code well in simple terms this
keyword basically just references the
object that is executing the current
function
now if the function that is being
referenced is a regular function then
this keyword references the global
object
all right I'm sure it must be a little
tricky at the moment but please hold on
and if the function that is being
referenced is a method in an object then
this keyword references the object
itself
so to help you understand the concept
better and to clarify all your doubts
let's look at a simple demo
so here in vs code I've created a file
called this.html all right you can give
it a name of your choice now here let me
first
Define a variable
and let's call the variable say
value and let's set it to say 50. all
right now let's go ahead and create a
simple function
so let me say function
[Music]
my function
all right and within this let me Define
the value for Value let me set the value
for the variable value as 100.
okay
and now let me just alert it all right
so let me say alert
value
[Music]
okay plus value
and then let me have another alert
message
which is going to display this dot value
so let me just say this value
[Music]
and instead of just saying value I say
this dot value
all right now after this let's go ahead
and call the function
my function
so let me just save this and execute it
so here it says value equals 100
and then when you see this dot value it
says 50. so now here you can come back
to the code and see now when I just say
value it takes the value 100 all right
which is taken locally but when I say
this dot value since it is a normal
function its references to the global
variable which is here
this value
I hope this makes sense to you now
now moving on let's look at the behavior
of the this keyword within an object
method
so let me create an object here
uh but before that let me just comment
this out
say script
and now let's create an object so
let's say const
and then I give the name of my object as
random
and within this let me say name and
let's call it
John
and then I create a method called info
okay and within this I display a console
message that says hi
my name is
and now I make use of this keyword I say
this
dot name
all right and now let me just go ahead
and call this method so I say random
dot info
all right so let's save this and execute
it
so let me check my console
and there you go it says hi my name is
John
so if you clearly observe here when we
say this dot name since it is being used
within a method that is defined in
Saturn object
it references to this property here
all right unlike this case where it
reference to the global variable that
was mentioned outside
so I hope this helped you understand the
difference between the two
now let's look at another simple example
so now let me just change the value of
name here
to say tutorial
and now let's define another property
which is basically an array so let me
just call the property video
within which I have an array let's say
JavaScript
another value
save this
and then let's say keyword
add in my info method I'm going to just
display these video tags so let me just
save this
okay let me just delete this first
and let's see this dot video
now since it's an array we can make use
of for each
and now for each in turn takes a
callback function
and then I say
I'm going to call it
a tag
the parameter that's being passed within
which I just console log it
and say tag
all right so let me save it
and then execute this
now here you can see that the values in
the video property are displayed that is
Javascript this and keyword
now let's suppose that you want to
display the name along with every string
here right so naturally you would go
ahead and just say
this dot name
right it makes perfect sense
so let me just save and execute this
now if you see just the values of the
property video are displayed here
now the main reason for this is if you
closely observe that this function here
is mentioned within the Callback
function
right so when it is referencing it is
referencing to the global object which
is unclear which is undefined in this
case so to overcome this what we can do
is that the for each method takes in two
properties one is the function the other
one is the object so here we just pass
this
all right so what happens is it's going
to reference the current object That Is
Random so let me save this and then
execute it
and there you go
you can see that tutorial that is the
name has been displayed
all right I hope you understood the
concept of this keyword it could be a
little tricky but as you work on it
you'll get the hang of it
in today's video we're going to learn
all about JavaScript functions in our
previous videos we cover topics like
JavaScript arrays and loops if you're
new to this topic I suggest you go
through these topics before
all right so before jumping in let's go
ahead and look at what's in store for us
first we're going to learn what exactly
JavaScript functions are
then we look at JavaScript function
Expressions then the function
Constructor self-invoking functions
functions as values functions as objects
Arrow functions generator function and
the predefined functions
also don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and hit the Bell icon to never
miss an update
moving on to our first topic what are
JavaScript functions
so basically a function is a group of
reusable code which can be called from
anywhere in your program right
when you have a piece of code that you
want to execute repeatedly in your
entire program it makes more sense to
Define it once and call it over and over
right it makes the code more efficient
and readable this also helps programmers
write modular codes
so this is the syntax you make use of
the function keyword followed by which
you mention the name of the function
the name of the function is completely
your choice next you mentioned the
parameter list and within curly braces
you can Define the function now the
function body is basically the code that
is executed every time the function is
called
so let's go to our vs code editor
and here I've created a folder called
demo functions within which I've created
an HTML file called functions.html
all right and now I've just typed in the
initial code
now let's create a function
so let me say script
within which I use the keyword that is
function keyword
and now I give
the name for my function I say my
underscore function
and the function takes a parameter save
value now this function basically
Returns the square of the digit all
right so within which
I say
document dot get element by ID
the ID is demo
and now it just displays value into
value
all right so the function basically
displays the square of the number
now outside the function let me call the
function
because
my function let me pass the value 5.
all right now let's save this and
execute it
so let me go back to my file
and here we go it displays the value 25
so this was a simple function which took
a value
a digit as a parameter and then returned
the square
moving on to the next concept function
expression now what we learned
previously was function declaration but
a function can also be defined as an
expression now this is what the syntax
looks like
now here the function is created and
assigned to the variable explicitly like
any other value the meaning Remains the
Same that is you create the function and
store the value that it returns into a
variable and in our case it's X right so
let's go to our vs core and let me help
you understand this better
so now
I create another function
and here I say let
x equals let's use a simpler function so
I just mentioned function
and within curly braces I display an
alert message and I display a message
saying hello
all right
now
after that to display the message what
we can do is let me just copy this
output
code
if you paste it here
and here what we're going to be
displaying is the value X right now
since it consists of a function you'll
have to type the curly braces now this
is crucial for its execution all right
so let me save this and then execute
let me execute this
and here you go it says the site says
hello so we've successfully executed the
piece of code we can also assign this
variable X to another variable and then
call that variable instead
right we can say let
Y equals X
and instead of calling X here
we can simply call Y
let me save it and then let me refresh
the page
and there we go it's still displays a
message hello
all right so this is one of the ways of
defining a function that is as an
expression
moving on to our next concept function
Constructor
now JavaScript functions are defined
using the keyword function right now
functions can also be defined using a
JavaScript built-in function
now this is the basic syntax so here
we've created a function called my
function and we've used the keyword new
after which we've used the Constructor
function
and inside we provide the parameter list
after that the return value
next you can call the function here
right so let me just go back to my vs
code
and now
let me just make changes to the same
piece of code here
I create a function say my underscore
function
okay all right let me just change the
name
to my function all right
and then here I use the keyword new
and the function Constructor that is
function
foreign within which I'm passing all the
parameters so I have
a b and I'm going to return the sum of
the digits
all right
and now while calling the function
let me just store the value in a
variable say X
and let's call the function that is my
function
with the parameters 2 and 3.
all right
and now let me just play it so I'm just
gonna copy this
and I want to display the value of x
right
all right so let me save this and
execute it
if you refresh the page it displays the
sum that is 5.
to make it more readable let me just
display another message here
let me just say
the sum is
all right
let me save it and then refresh the page
it says the sum is 5.
all right now this is how you make use
of the function Constructor
next up we learn about self invoking
functions
now as the name suggests these functions
are invoked automatically without being
called now previously when we learned
about function Expressions we saw that
parentheses were crucial
so you have to add parentheses around
the function to indicate that it is a
function expression so here is a Syntax
for you so what we've done is we've made
sure we've enclosed the entire function
within parentheses
so let me help you with that let's go
back to our vs code
and let me create another script
and here let me create the function
within the parentheses and say function
it's not taking any parameters
instead it is going to
alert for message so let me say
hello welcome
right
after which
we're going to call the function so
again we have to mention the parentheses
let's save this
and execute
so when we refresh the page it says
hello welcome
so we never call the function rather it
got invoked by itself so these are
self-invoking functions
now let's go ahead and look at functions
as values
now in JavaScript a function is
basically a value so we can deal with it
as a value now here is a simple syntax
now if you closely look at the syntax
you might think that this is same as
function Expressions well no in this
case what we do is we first Define the
function and then we assign it to a
particular variable but in the case of
Expressions the function definition was
defined during the initialization of the
variable right and also we have to
specify the parenthesis in order to call
the function so to help you understand
this better let me go back to our vs
code and here
let me just erase this
and let's define a function that Returns
the product of two digits so let me just
call it product
which takes two parameters let me say A
and B
within which we return the value
a into B
all right now after this let's create
another variable say y
equals function oh I'm sorry the name of
the function is product so product of 2
and 5.
right so this basically returns US 10
right so let me just copy this to
display this on our web page
and here I change the message to the
product
and here let me change it to y
so let's save this and execute it
so let me refresh the page and here you
go you can see the message the product
is done
now what we can do is we can make
alterations to this now say I want to
multiply the value
with 5 again
right so basically this returns 10 and
that value is multiplied by 5. so let me
save this
and refresh our page and there we go it
returns
and there we go it displays 50. so this
is how you can make use of functions as
values
moving on to the next topic functions as
objects
now JavaScript functions are a special
type of objects called function objects
now a function includes a string which
holds the actual code that is the
function body of the function the code
is literally just a string although not
recommended you can also create a
function with the help of the function
Constructor I will show that you a
little later on but for now let's look
at the syntax
now here we have a variable called body
which basically consists of the function
body its enclosed in double quotes and
that's a mistake please ignore it all
right so next we have variable function
name so here we create a function using
the keyword new and then we pass a
parameter list and the body basically
tells us what the function returns right
next we have an alert message to call
the function so let me just show how
this is executed
create another
function
and let's say the function Returns the
area of a circle right so let me just
create
a body variable
which returns
so the area of circle is pi R square so
we make use of math dot pi
into radius
into radius right
so it's basically Pi R square
after which
let's see where Circle
[Music]
and here let's create a function using
the new keyword
function
and then here we pass
the value that is the radius
and then the body
right so basically this is the
definition of our function
so let's use alert
to display the area so we say alert of
circle
or five
all right let me save this and execute
it
so when you refresh the page
it displays the area of the circle
so this is how you can use functions as
objects
moving on to our next concept Arrow
functions
now functions can be written more
compactly and more precisely with the
help of Arrow functions all right now
Arrow function expressions are
Illustrated as methods and they cannot
be used as Constructors
now also while using Arrow functions
using const is a safer option because a
function expression is always a constant
value
so this is the syntax now you can only
omit the return keyword within the curly
braces if the function is a single
statement
so this is the syntax first you provide
the name of the function
with an equal to sign followed by the
argument list and later you make use of
this Arrow icon and Define the
expression
so this is basically nothing but this
so let's go back to our vs code and
check for ourselves
so let's create another function
and here let me say
const
my funk
equals now say we want to display the
product of three digits so let me just
pass ABC as my parameters
and we make use of this icon which
indicates that this is an arrow function
within which I say return a into B into
C
all right
now let me just assign this to a
variable
okay let me say
product because we've used X here
and then let me call my function that is
my func and pass the value 2 3 and say
4.
all right so let's display the product
so let me just copy this
code
and here let me see the product
of the three
digits is
and let me say product here because that
is what is being used here right all
right so let me save this and execute it
all right first it displays the area of
the circle all right and then we say
okay
and there we go it displays the message
the product of the three digits is 24.
so let me do one thing let me just
comment this out
okay
let me save it and then execute it again
it just displays this
all right so this is how we can make use
of Arrow functions
moving on let's look at the generator
function
now regular functions typically return
only one value right or a single value
or sometimes even nothing but a
generator function can return multiple
values and the specialty is that it can
do it so on demand all right now to
create a generator function we make use
of an asterisk
so an asterisk indicates that the
function is a generator function
so here you can see that we have a
function followed by asterisks and we've
created a function called generator
sequence
so here you can see we have the
asterisks after the keyword function
followed by the name of the function
right
but the main method of a generator
function is the next method when this
method is called it basically runs the
execution until the nearest yield value
all right all the nearest yield
statement
then the function execution pauses and
the yielded value is returned to the
outer code
all right so the result of the next
method is always an object with two
properties it has a value property which
is basically the yielded value
and then it has a done property which
displays true if the function code is
finished or false if it's otherwise so
let me show its execution for a clearer
understanding so let's go back to our vs
code
and here let's create the generator
function
let's say function asterisk
generate
function all right
now within which
I make use of the keyword yield
and I say yield one first
followed by yield
and finally I make use of return which
indicates the termination so I say
return 3.
all right
now we make use of
a variable say generator
and assign it to the generator function
that is generate
funk
and now I create another variable say 1.
which will basically return the value
when I call the next function so here I
say generator
dot next
okay so whatever generator dot next
returns it's stored in one
so to display the message I say alert
and now I'm going to make use of a
method called Json Dot stringify
[Music]
all right so basically this method
converts a JavaScript object or a value
to a Json string
alright so within which I'm going to say
1.
that is this
all right
so now let me save this
and execute it
Let me refresh the page and there you go
here it returns
two properties that is value and done it
says value is 1 and done is false right
it is false because we haven't reached
the return statement yet
foreign
so what we can do is to display the rest
let me just copy these
and display it one by one
see there let's see this
and here let me say two
and this is three
let me copy this
[Music]
okay here I say two
and then I say three
all right so let me save this and then
execute it
so when I refresh the page it says one
and false
after which again it says true and false
and finally when it displays 3 it
returns true for the done property that
means we've reached the end of the
function definition
so this is how you make use of a
generator function
now let's move on to our last topic that
is predefined functions
now JavaScript has many built-in
functions all right now here are a few
of them we have eval parseint pass float
escape and unescape now let's go through
one by one
all right first up is eval now this
basically evaluates a string and returns
a value all right so to help you
understand this better let me go back to
our vs code
and now let me just create another file
and let me call it redefined
functions.html all right
and I've just copied the initial code
all right so for eval the syntax is eval
within which
I see expression
all right now this is the general syntax
so what this eval does is that it
evaluates the expression
and if the result is not a string the
result is just returned and the result
is a string it is taken to be a
JavaScript program and evaluated
so let me show you how it's done
so first let's create three variables
all right let's call them X
and initialize it to five
then y with six
and then let Z be 7 all right
now let's just displace the result on
the console so say console.log
eval
or let me say X Plus y
all right
after which I again say console.log
of event of set
here since the expression is a string
this gets evaluated and here since it's
not a string it just Returns the value Z
and here since it is not a string it
just Returns the value of Z so let me
save this and then execute it
all right so let me just
check
our console
there you go it evaluated the expression
and added the two values that is X and Y
and returned 11.
while Z is returned as it is
all right this is what eval does
next up is parsaint now as the name
suggests it passes a string argument and
returns an integer of the specified
Radix or base
and the syntax basically includes the
keyword parse and the string within
parenthesis
parse float on the other hand passes a
string argument and returns a floating
Point number again the syntax has the
keyword pass float along with the string
within parenthesis
next up is escape now this Returns the
hexadecimal encoding of an argument
and on the other hand unescape Returns
the ASCII string for the specified value
so what exactly is form validation
now I am sure you must have filled
several online forms right a simple
example would be a new registration for
a website
now every time you miss out on giving a
particular detail or end up giving
faulty information the website alerts
you
so this process of ensuring that the
information provided is legit is called
form validation
now this generally happens on the server
side however JavaScript facilitates form
validation on the client computer before
sending it over to the server now there
are two functions performed one is the
basic validation which ensures that all
the mandatory fields are filled now this
is implemented with the help of a simple
Loop
and the other is a data format
validation now this checks the data for
its correctness
so to help you understand form
validation better let's look at a simple
demo
all right so back in my visual studio
code I've created a file called forms
all right it's an HTML file and I've
typed down the initial code
now the simple use case that I'm going
to show will include the validation of
the email and the password fields in a
form all right so for that let's go
ahead and first create a simple form
so here HTML allows the form tag so I
say form
within which I'm going to provide our
Fields so I say input
and then the name I'm going to be
providing is email
[Music]
all right and then I'll provide a
placeholder and call it email
and then the type of the input is going
to be text
all right and then let me just give a
free attacker
so now let me just copy the same thing
for my password as well
so here you go I say
password Here
and then the placeholder again will be
password
[Music]
and then I'm going to keep the type as
text
and finally I'm going to have a button a
submit button right so let me say button
type is basically submit
okay
and let me just please submit on my
button all right
okay so with the input this we've
created a simple form so let me show you
how this looks
so here we go we've successfully created
an email field a password field and a
submit button and every time I click on
the submit button you can see that my
page is getting refreshed
now once the user provides the correct
email ID and password we want to display
a message all right so for that I've
created another file called message.html
and this is a simple file where I'm
displaying the message hello there
welcome
all right so this is a simple message
that I want to display so for that I
have to add it in my form tag
now once the form gets submitted
an action has to be performed and the
action is to navigate to the
message.html file right so let me just
say action
[Music]
equals
message for HTML
now you can also provide a name to your
form so let me call it
my form
all right
so let me just save this
all right so moving on we have to now
validate the information that is
provided for that I'm going to create a
function here
so let me call the function
validate
all right
so here I'm going to check my Fields
right now if the email field is empty
then I'm going to alert the user saying
please enter the email
and if the password field is empty I'm
gonna again alert the user to provide
the password
so for that we're going to make use of
this simple if else logic so let me say
if
document
dot my form
[Music]
dot email
dot value is null
so I'm going to check if the value
provided on my email field in my form
is null all right
what I'm going to do is I'm going to say
alert
please provide
your
email ID
okay
and then I'm going to say
document.myform
dot email dot Focus now what exactly
Focus does is that it makes sure that
the cursor remains at the email field
that is focus
so let me just copy the same thing for
my password field
so let me say else if
let me just copy this
[Music]
instead of email I say password
within which I'm going to alert the user
to provide the password
[Music]
I'll say please provide
your password
all right
so basically it first checks for the
email field and then for the password
field so let me just say finally else
do nothing
all right
okay so now what we're going to do is
every time we click on the submit button
the form gets submitted correct now we
can control when the form is getting
submitted
so basically the form gets submitted
when this function is executed
so for that we can use another property
here
called on submit
and here I'm going to call my function
that is validate so let me say validate
here
all right so let me save this and let's
check the output
so here as you can see
let me just try submitting it without
providing the email field all right so
here we go it alerts us all right and
once I click on OK
it still displays the message hello
there welcome now that is not what we
want right so once the email field is
empty it should remain in the same page
and the form shouldn't get submitted but
here in our case it is getting submitted
so for that we're going to have to make
use of return values so what happens is
if my email field is empty then I'm
going to return a false so here I say
return false
and here as well
and finally when both my email and my
password fields are filled I'm going to
return true
all right
and same goes here
let me just say return validate instead
of just validate right
so
here we go
let me save this and now let's check the
output so here let's first submit the
form without providing any information
all right so it says Please provide your
email ID when I click on OK observe that
the cursor remains at the email field
so here let me just give some random
value
and then let's try submitting it again
without providing the password
and that says Please provide your
password
all right
okay now if You observe that the cursor
is remains at the email field so let me
just check my code once
here we go I haven't mentioned password
Here
so let me change email to password
so let me just provide some random value
at my email field
and say submit
and when I get a message saying please
provide your password
and now you can see that the cursor is
at the password field right so let me
just give random information there
and then I say submit
and here we go the message hello there
welcome is displayed
so this was a simple demo on form
validation
so I really suggest you pause the video
here and then go through the code once
so what exactly are regular Expressions
now a regular expression is basically a
sequence of characters now these
characters could be digits or the
letters of the alphabet and this
expression usually searches for a
particular pattern now the user can
basically Define what has to be searched
in a text all right and these
Expressions could be alphabet or digits
as I explained before
also one of the main reasons that we use
regular Expressions is for text search
and text replacement operations
so this is a general syntax you have a
pattern that needs to be checked and you
have a flag associated with it so
further on in the video I'll explain to
you what flags and patterns are but
before that let me give you a small
example of what a regular expression is
so I have made use of this website
called regexr.com I'll link it down in
the description box below
so this is the website now here let me
just show you a simple regular
expression now say we have a text that
says Apple
all right and now we have to search for
the letter A so what I do here now this
is going to be my expression so I first
provide a pattern right so I just say
capital a
so when I say capital A you can see that
the letter A has been matched in my text
all right so it's as simple as that now
one thing to remember is that here it is
case sensitive all right so if I say
a regular small a it does not get
matched
all right so if I want to match AP I can
just say AP and it gets highlighted here
all right so this is a simple regular
expression that matches with the text
so moving on
let's see what exactly these flags
patterns and quantifiers are
so what exactly is a flag so we
previously saw that the syntax consists
of a pattern and then a flag right so
these flags basically specify to alter
the behavior of a regular expression now
these flags are generally appended after
the records literal and can be specified
as a second argument in your expression
right so let's see the different flags
that are supported by JavaScript
now you have these Five Flags here you
have G which is a global flag now this
file all matches instead of stopping
after the first all right then you have
I which is ignore case which makes the
entire expression case insensitive and
then you have M which is multi-line
so the carrot and the dollar match the
beginning and the end of each line
respectively then you have Unicode and
if this flag is not supported you must
match specific Unicode characters and
then finally you have Y which finds all
the consecutive or adjacent matches
so moving on we have patterns now these
patterns are basically brackets and are
used to find the range of characters now
again we have these patterns we have a
to z which finds all the characters from
A to Z in lower cases only then we have
0 to 9 which finds all the digits
between 0 to 9 and finally we have the
letters of the alphabet and the digits
separated by a pipe all right so this
basically finds any character be it an
alphabet or a digit
I hope this was clear to you so moving
on we have quantifiers now these
quantifiers Define the number of
occurrences of a particular string now
consider n to be a string so we have
three quantifiers here we have the plus
we have the asterisks and we have the
question mark so plus indicates one or
more occurrence of the character n all
right and the asterisk indicates zero or
more occurrences of the character end
while a question mark indicates 0 or 1
occurrence of the character n so now
that you know Flags patterns and
quantifiers let me help you understand
them better with the help of a demo
all right so here I have a simple text
which says welcome to this tutorial on
JavaScript this video teaches regular
expressions
now here when I search for a particular
word say let me search for the word this
okay so I say this
now ideally even this has to be
highlighted right however it does not
that is because as mentioned earlier it
is extremely case sensitive right so
what we can do is here we have Flags
so here I say case insensitive so once I
click on that both these words get
highlighted
all right so this was how you make use
of the eye flag
now moving on let me help you understand
patterns now as mentioned you can have a
range of characters now just in case
here
[Music]
say I just make it case sensitive again
and here I would like to select all the
letters of the alphabet
from A to Z
all right so when I do that you can
observe all the letters are highlighted
except the ones that are in the upper
case
correct because that is not mentioned
here so here when I make it insensitive
you can see all of them get highlighted
so this is how you can make use of a
pattern
now to understand quantifiers let me use
a separate text all right let's have a
couple of A's and a few V's
now here when I say A you can see all
the characters a are being highlighted
right which is correct but when I use
the asterisks simply here what happens
is you can observe all the Four A's are
considered to be a single unit what
asterisks does is that you can see here
it says matches zero or more of the
preceding token now the preceding token
is a and matches 0 or more occurrences
of the character a
now same if I say B next to it you can
see all the characters B are matched
right
however you can check
the characters a in this particular text
are not highlighted
I'm sure you can understand why because
the expression that I'm looking for is
any occurrences of a
followed by the character B in this text
here there are no characters A and B
together correct so here you can say
that a is not highlighted
but once a given asterisks again what
happens is that the character a gets
highlighted what happens is that B can
have 0 or more occurrences so here there
is a zero occurrence of B so a gets
highlighted so this is how the asterisk
quantifier works
now one of the most important concepts
of using regular expressions are the
special characters so here we're gonna
indicate the special characters with the
backslash
so we have backslash W for example now
what w does is that it matches any word
character right so all the characters
here get matched
now it also has a counter character
which is the capital W all right so what
this does is that it does not match any
word so it matches everything that is
not a word including the periods
now let's see if you want to match
all the white spaces you can make use of
the character s here
all right and when you have the
uppercase s it matches any character
that is not a white space
now let's say you want to match
a digit you can just have backslash d so
let me just type in a few digits and
here you go all of them get matched
now let's say you want to have a range
of values that get matched right now
let's say I want to match just three
digits so I can make use of curly braces
and within which I can mention three now
here you can see that it matches three
of the preceding token correct so the
preceding token is basically a digit so
it groups them in threes
so let me just add two other digits and
there we go
same goes with the matching of words so
here let me say w
so when I say three all of the
characters are grouped in threes all
right now let's say I want to prove the
words that are three or four numbers so
here I can just say
comma 4
all right now it gets matched
all right so now it gets grouped in
force so this is a simple example to
show you how special characters work in
a regular expression
moving on let's see how you can use
regular Expressions to search for phone
numbers
now here in my phone number
I'm going to have an area code so let's
say 0 is 0 followed by a new digit
number all right so let me give a random
number
[Music]
all right so it's eight digits so some
people write a phone number like this
While others could write it something
like this you could have a hyphen in
between and then
any digit number all right now how are
you going to look for this text so what
we're gonna do is we're going to make
use of the special character that is for
a digit you make use of hyphen d
and first we're going to look for the
area code that is a three digit number
right so let me just say
three here and next we're going to have
an optional hyphen so for that now since
we learned a pattern can be enclosed
within square brackets so let me just
say hyphen here
and let me say a question mark now a
question mark indicates 0 or 1
occurrence of the preceding character
right so we're going to have a hyphen
for a question mark and then finally
we're gonna have a digit again
and here the number of digits is eight
so let me just specify that
all right so when this happens you can
see both my numbers are getting
highlighted
although the text Remains the Same it
could be specified with different
formats right so just like this you can
create Expressions that match various
formats so this was just a simple video
to a queen to with regular expressions
in today's session we're going to be
learning all about JavaScript email
validation
so first of all validation is an
essential part when you're communicating
with the user almost all the websites
and applications that you use have forms
that you need to fill in and every time
you fill a form that information you
provide needs to be validated
so this is an essential and a crucial
part now when you're providing more
critical information like user
credentials say your ID your password
your date of birth all of that needs to
be validated so JavaScript enables this
with the help of a feature called email
validation
now email validation first of all
ensures user authenticity it also
facilitates email validation on the
client side so that all the processing
that takes place on the server side is
faster
and lastly with JavaScript one can
validate a name password email date Etc
now I'm sure everybody has used email
IDs right so here's a dummy email ID for
you one thing that you must have noticed
is that all IDs come with an ad symbol
now the first part before the ads
character is the personal data now here
it could include your name you can
provide digits Etc so the length of this
personal information can be up to 64
degrees and following the at character
you have the domain name the domain name
can be up to 253 characters
talking about the personal data now this
data can include any sort of information
you can provide your name your birth
date Etc so basically it can consist of
all uppercase and lowercase letters of
the alphabet
it can have digits from 0 to 9
it can include all special characters
and lastly it could include the period
character one thing to remember is that
the period character cannot occur twice
and is not supposed to be either the
first or the last character
all right so this was just a brief
introduction to email validation now to
give you a better understanding let's go
ahead and look at a simple demo
so back in our Visual Studio code I've
created a folder called JavaScript demo
and I've also created a file called
email validation
I've also typed in the initial code also
if you haven't watched our videos on
JavaScript regular expressions and
JavaScript form validation then I highly
recommend you go through them
email validation is basically just a
combination of the two so I'd suggest
you first head back and watch those
videos and come back here all right so
the first thing that we need to do is
create a form that includes the email
field right so for that let's go ahead
and create a form
here I'd say
form
within which add give input
let the ID be text
and I'll give the placeholder property
and let it be email
and the type
text
all right and then I will
break the line
and finally I have a button that's
basically the submit button right so let
me just say button
type
save button
and then the message displayed is submit
all right so now when you're validating
a form you will have to provide certain
cases that is the if else conditions to
validate it correct now first I'm going
to create a function wherein I'm going
to pass the information typed in by the
user as an argument and this function
consists of a regular expression against
which the ID provided by the user is
checked and if the pattern matches it
then the ID is valid and if it is not
then you'll have to alert the user so
now let's create our function
let's see script
and now let me
create a function
called validate
all right
and now I'm going to create a variable
called mail
I'm going to get
the information provided by using this
ID from the input now I'm going to get
the text using this ID correct so let me
just say document dot get element by ID
within which
the name of the ID is text
let me say text Dot value all right
so the next thing is to create a regular
expression
now consider two different IDs here now
the domain of the first ID ends with.com
while the next one is ending with DOT Co
dot in so when we're defining the
regular expression we'll consider all
possible scenarios so now let's head
back to our vs code
and here let me just see
variable reg X
beginning with a forward slash
and then you have
a carrot now the carrot symbol indicates
the beginning of the regular expression
now since we can have the lowercases
uppercases and all the digits
let's go ahead and mention them so here
let me say A to Z all lower cases then
we have uppercase
and we have all digits
0 to 9
followed by which we can also include a
period and an underscore so when you're
including a period symbol you will have
to use the Escape character that is
backslash
and then you mention the period now one
thing to remember is that a period
symbol in regular expression means that
it can include any of the characters but
here since we're using the literal
character that is the period we have to
include backslash after that we can have
an underscore as well
all right
followed by which we have a quantifier
that is plus now plus here indicates one
or more occurrences of all these
characters so here we include Plus
after which we have a literal that is
the ax symbol
followed by which we have the domain
name so again the domain name can
include all the letters of the alphabet
and the digits
so for that let me say
A to Z
A to Z and 0 to 9.
again to remember we have to include the
plus symbol
indicating that it
okay let me just get rid of this
so we include the plus symbol to
indicate one or more occurrences of of
these characters
again followed by which we have a period
symbol
so for that let's just go and type in
Period now you must be wondering why I
didn't use the backslash
um now a backslash or an escape sequence
here can only be used within the squared
braces outside of it it is considered as
a literal
so here I just mentioned the period
again I highly recommend you go through
the JavaScript regular Expressions video
to clarify all your nouns
so moving on after this I have to
mention the extension that is.com or dot
Co Dot N
now generally these extensions are in
lower cases so for that let's just
go ahead and mention e to Z again
followed by a plus that is a quantifier
with an optional
dot again
followed by the letters a to z
again these can
again I mentioned Plus
followed by which I'm going to add the
question mark
now the question mark indicates 0 or 1
occurrence of the preceding expression
so in this case
this
extension that is dot in is optional now
the question mark here indicates either
a zero occurrence or one occurrence
all right
so to end the expression you have
the dollar symbol and then the front
slash I might have missed something
okay yeah I haven't closed this so let
me just add the parenthesis all right
so this is your regular expression
against which we're going to be checking
the email ID right
so now we're going to use the simple if
else logic
so for that let's say if
reg X
dot text
dot Main
mail is basically what has been passed
by the user
all right now if this is true
that is if the mail went checked against
the regular expression comes in to be
true
then I'm going to alert the user sing
you have
[Music]
provided
um
a valid email ID
and I'm going to return true
else
if the expression does not match
then I'm going to alert the user with a
message
saying sorry
incorrect
email ID
and I'm going to return a false
so now you must be wondering where is
the return value going so for that I
have to add the on click event on my
button
so here let me say on click
it's going to call the validate function
all right so there we go let me save
this
and execute it
in my browser when I type in XYZ
gmail.com and when I click on submit
it alerts me saying you have provided a
valid email ID so to check the other
condition as well let's type in dot Co
Dot N and submit
and again it says I will provided a
valid email ID
now let's just add a period and an
underscore as well
so if I say x y z
Dot
a underscore BC gmail.com
and when I submit it it again says it's
a valid email ID
for a false case let's go ahead and
remove the ad symbol
and submit it which says sorry incorrect
email ID
or you can also go ahead and remove the
period here
I'm going to submit it it still says
that the ID is valid now here what
happens is that Gmail Co is taken as one
domain name with an extension dot in so
here this is valid so this was a simple
video to explain email validation
I encourage you to play around with
regular expressions and also uh consider
all possible scenarios while you're
validating your ID in our previous few
topics you learned about arrays
functions in Loops however this time we
are going to take a step forward and
then learn about promises
now You Must Be Wondering Why JavaScript
promises even came into picture and what
exactly these promises are
so don't worry I've got your back in
today's video we're going to learn about
promises why they were introduced and
also I'll explain their functionality
so let's go ahead
first up why JavaScript promises
now JavaScript is predominantly single
threaded meaning
all processes contain the execution of
instructions in a single sequence so
basically in simple terms one command is
processed at a time now if a function
relies on the result of another function
it basically has to wait for the other
function to finish and return and until
then the current function remains idle
now this can be extremely frustrating
because a time consuming and very
restrictive I mean you're not using the
system to its full capability so to
overcome these drawbacks asynchronous
Concepts or asynchronous programming
came into picture
so in this case the main thread
continues its execution while JavaScript
allows long Network requests and other
tasks to happen simultaneously
now with the help of features like
callbacks promises and async await
asynchronous programming can be easily
achieved
I hope now you understood why promises
or asynchronous programming came into
picture
moving on what are JavaScript promises
now in the case of synchronous actions
you could instead of arranging for a
function to be called at some point in
the future return an object that
represents this future event
this is what the standard class promise
is for now the promise is basically an
asynchronous action that may complete at
some point in the future
and when it's completed it produces a
value
now it is able to notify when its value
is available
the easiest way to create a promise is
by calling the promise.resolve method
now this function ensures that the value
you give it is wrapped within a promise
now a problem is basically has three
states first up is the pending State now
this indicates that the underlying
operation has not yet been completed
next up is the fulfill State this
indicates that the promise has been
fulfilled with a particular value
lastly we have rejected now this
indicates that an error has occurred
during the operation and the promise is
rejected with the particular reason
Moving On A promise is said to be
settled when it is either fulfilled or
rejected
because remember promises are immutable
they cannot change their state so once
they're either fulfilled or rejected
they said to be settled
so when a promise is fulfilled it has to
do a particular job so for that we make
use of the then method now the then
method basically runs for a result and
this is used to attach a callback when
the promise has been resolved all right
same with the case of the scenario when
the promise is rejected it makes use of
a catch method which is used to attach a
callback when the promise has been
rejected don't worry you'll understand
the concepts better when we get to the
demo
so moving on let's look at a quick
flowchart to understand promises better
first up you have a new promise now the
promise is in the pending state
now this promise runs for an
asynchronous action now we check if the
action is successful if it is a yes then
we call the then method and if it is a
no then the catch method is called
and to end it if it is fulfilled then
the asynchronous action is performed and
if it is not that is if it is rejected
then error handling is performed
and lastly the values of these methods
is returned to the promise
I hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the
general syntax
you can use a LED keyword and provide a
name for your variable and then you
create a new promise now this promise
object takes a function which in turn
takes two parameters that is resolved
and reject
so to help you understand all of this
better let's go ahead and look at a
simple demo
so in vs code I've created a folder
called demo promises within which I've
created an HTML file named promises so I
have the initial code ready here
so let's begin typing our code
so let's see script
and here as I explained we say let and
let's give the name car
to our variable say car and we create a
new promise
all right so the promise object returns
a function which takes two parameters
called resolve
and reject
all right
So within the function
let's define
a simple use case now let's assume that
we're checking the car for its fuel all
right so we'll create variable called
fuel
underscore full tank
now let's set the variable to say true
all right now let's set the variable to
true
now this indicates that the fuel tank is
full
so now if the fuel tank is full
what I can do is I say resolve
all right
else I reject it
okay I hope you understood what I'm
doing here I'm just checking for the
fuel tank and if it is full which is
true then it gets resolved and if it is
false then it gets rejected
so if the promise gets resolved the then
method is called right so let me call it
here I say car dot then
now this runs a result right so it's a
callback function
which in which I say document dot right
the fuel
tank is full
happy driving
[Music]
all right
and if it is
rejected
I say dot catch
[Music]
which also returns a function
that says document
dot right
let's just display a simple message
saying that the fuel tank is not empty
[Music]
all right so let me save this and
execute it
so here it displays the message the fuel
tank is full happy driving
now that happens because we've set the
value to True here now in case we change
it to false
let's see what it displays
all right it displays the message the
fuel tank is not empty
so this was a simple example showing how
a promise works
now let's go ahead and understand nested
promises so for that let me just comment
this out
[Music]
and now let's create a function that
returns promises so in our case what
we're going to do is first we'll check
for the fuel tank now in our case we're
taking a scenario where the fuel tank is
empty and the engine of the car is
overheating so as a result the car is
not safe for traveling all right so
let's go ahead and create these
functions
so I'll say net
empty underscore
tank
okay which returns
a promise
So within which I say return
new promise
[Music]
and the function takes two parameters
that is resolved
and reject
which in which I am going to display a
message saying resolve
which is the car
doesn't
have enough fuel
all right
now let me just copy the same piece of
code
to check for the engine all right
so let me just change the name of our
variable here
let's call it engine
and here it displays the message
the engine is overheating
all right and lastly
when both of these scenarios holds row
that is the car doesn't have enough fuel
and the engine is overheating
we say that the car is not fit for
travel
let me just call it
and here
I'll display a message saying the car is
not safe for traveling
[Music]
all right
so right now we've created three
functions that returns promises
so first we check for the empty tank
right so let me just call the function
here
empty tank
and we make use of the then method
which is executed when the promise gets
resolved
which takes
[Music]
a callback function
all right so basically when we check for
the empty tank
after this is executed we check for the
engine right so here we simply call the
engine function so let me just say
return
engine
all right
now this is a nested promise in itself
so on top of it I can run the then
method again
[Music]
so if the tank is empty and if the
engine is overheating then I'll just
check if it is safe for traveling or not
so let me see
function
and here let me just return
the method travel
all right
now after this
if all of these are executed then I say
function
finally I'll display a message
saying
same done
all right
so let's save this file and execute it
here I go ahead and click on promises
[Music]
let's go and check our console
and there we go the message done is
displayed
so here since every time the promise is
being resolved a message is displayed I
can basically catch the message in a
result
okay and this result can be passed to
the coming methods so here I just say
result
again
[Music]
all right
so now we get the message the car
doesn't have enough fuel so we have to
append it with the next message so let
me just say message here
I've used MSG
[Music]
and let's just append it here
good result
okay I have to add message here as well
all right so let's save it and execute
the file
all right so here you can see the
message done gets displayed first and
then since we're appending it after the
message done it says the car doesn't
have enough fuel the engine is
overheating the car is not safe for
traveling
so this was how you can make use of
nested promises in today's video we're
going to learn all about JavaScript
asynchronous concept that is async and
away
firstly let's understand the basic
concepts of synchronous and asynchronous
programming in case of synchronous
programming all the actions are
performed sequentially so you have the
execution of the function 1 after which
you have function 2 and then you have
function 3 and after all of these are
executed the program terminates now all
those synchronous programming is clean
and has lesser errors it has its own
drawbacks the entire system is halted
when a particular process is being
executed as a result of which it is time
consuming and the system is not used to
its full capacity
so to overcome that asynchronous
programming was introduced now in this
case let's assume that a particular
function or a process is being executed
now let's consider that this particular
function is waiting for a resource let's
say a network resource now instead of
waiting for the function to acquire this
resource the main thread continues its
execution with function 2 and function 3
and when the resource is acquired it
receives a callback indicating that the
function 1 has to be called and finally
the entire chain is terminated so this
is how asynchronous programming works it
makes sure that the system does not halt
when a particular process is waiting for
a resource this makes the entire system
very efficient
now that you know the concepts of
synchronous and asynchronous programming
let's move ahead now async innovate are
purely asynchronous programming Concepts
I again suggest you check out the video
on promises before watching this
alright so moving on
what are JavaScript async functions that
is async and await now async animate a
built on promises the function is
basically accompanied by the keyword
async indicating that it returns a
promise within this function the away
keyword is applied to the promise that
is being returned and the await keyword
ensures that the function waits for the
promise to resolve now on the surface
the execution looks synchronous while
it's actually asynchronous now add the
place of usage of the await keyword the
execution of the function is practically
blocked
now async functions make the code more
readable and are easy to handle when
compared to promises now to give you the
general syntax you have the async
keyword associated with the function
name within which we have the await
keyword with a particular promise now to
help you understand the entire concept
better let's look at a demo now I've
created a file called async await in my
visual studio code
so what we're going to be doing is that
we're going to have two functions that
help you check for the result now you
pass the score as a parameter to these
functions which in turn return promises
telling you to have passed and will also
give you the grade that you've scored
all right so let's go ahead and say let
me call the variable result and let's
have a function
which takes the score as a parameter all
right
within which it returns a promise so I
saved return new promise now as you know
a promise basically has a function
which takes two parameters that is
resolved
and reject
[Music]
now I just display a message saying
calculating
[Music]
results
all right now if
my score is C above 50
I resolve it by displaying a message
saying congratulations
[Music]
you have passed
all right and if it is less than 50
[Music]
I reject it with the message saying you
have faith
all right so this is a very simple
promise that I created
so moving on let's create another
function that returns a promise so
basically this function will tell you
the grade that you've scored so say let
grade equals
function
now this takes response as a parameter
so let me just say response
[Music]
again let me just copy this
all right within which I'm going to
console log this message
saying
calculating your grade
[Music]
and we're just going to resolve the
promise with the message
your grade is a all right
and then we append the response
[Music]
now the first promise either results
saying that you've passed or it rejects
saying you failed and in case it gets
resolved then the next promise is
automatically resolved with the grade A
all right so moving on
let's call the functions so here let me
first call the function result so I say
result
and let me pass the value 80 since it
gets resolved and now I make use of the
dot then method now here I catch the
response
all right and then I just display a
message indicating
results received
[Music]
okay
now what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna pass
the response to my next function that is
the grade function so what I say is I
say return
rate and the parameter is response so
let me just pass that now what exactly
happens is that the grade function also
returns a promise so on top of that I
can use the dot that method so I use the
then method
and let me just say final grade
[Music]
and within which I just displayed the
message
final grade
all right now lastly we make use of the
catch method
in case of errors this catches the
errors so let me just say error
and then
the console login
all right so this is the code let me
save this
and let's execute it to see its normal
execution so this is without using async
end of it all right
so let's go ahead and execute this
so here let me check the console
and there we go it says calculating
results results received calculating
your grade your grade is a and
congratulations you have passed so this
was basically without using async and
note8 so now let me show you how you can
use async in a weight and how easier the
code becomes all right so what we can do
is let me just comment this out
all right now what I'm gonna do is I'm
going to call my function right so I'm
just going to make use of the async
keyword while calling it so I say async
function and let me call the function
calculate
results
okay
so now inside this method I'm going to
call the functions result and grade so
when I first call result the value that
is returned by result is going to be
stored in the variable response so for
that let me just say const
response
now I make use of the await keyword here
I say await
result
or 20 or in our case let me just say 80.
all right so what the away keyword does
is that the function result ceases to
execute until the promise is resolved
and whatever the promise returns gets
stored in the variable response all
right so now after this let me just
display a message
that says results
received
all right now next I'm gonna call the
other function that is great so again
I'm going to say constant and I'm going
to have to create another variable let
me call it final grade and it's the same
procedure I use the await keyword
and call the function grade
and I pass response as the argument all
right
and after this I'm going to say console
log for final grade
so it's as simple as that so first we
call the result function which returns a
promise which gets stored in the
variable response all right then we're
going to call the grid function and pass
the response as an argument
and the result of which is being stored
in final grade all right and lastly we
display final grade so now you must be
wondering if this executes what about
errors what if the value that I pass is
less than 50 right for that I'm going to
have to catch an error
so what I can do is that I can place
this entire code within the try block
all right so let me just say try
and now what I can do is I can catch
now if there is an error it gets caught
and then I display it
say console log
all right
and lastly let's call the function
calculate results
okay so let me save this and execute it
so all right here we go it displays the
same messages in the same sequence that
we saw before
so now to give you an example of
rejection so here let me just pass 20.
all right
let's save it
and there we go it says calculating
results you have failed so you can make
use of async in await instead of
complicating the entire piece of Code by
using promises
but in this session we will be seeing
what exactly is Dom
which is document object model
and how can we manipulate the top how do
we interact with the Dom elements and
nodes
and then we will wrap up the session
with a very interesting and engaging
demo which is about movies so we'll be
creating a movie web page where you can
see the list of movies you can search
for these movies and we also can add a
new movie and delete them so these door
manipulations we'll be seeing for a
movie web page
so what is Dom
document object model
it is the data representation of the
objects that comprise the structure and
content of a document on the web
so this Dom is a programming interface
for HTML and XML documents and it
represents the page so that the programs
can change the document structure style
and content
Dom represents the document as nodes and
objects
this way programming languages can
connect to the page
a web page is a document
document can either be displayed in the
browser window or as an HTML source
but it is the same document in both the
cases
the document object model or Dom
represents the same document so it can
be manipulated
Dom is an object-oriented representation
of the web page which can be modified by
the scripting language very powerful
language like JavaScript
Dom is usually represented in a
hierarchical tree like structure
so you can see
this picture onto my right where you can
see a HTML element which will be the
root or the parent element and it has
two child elements that you can see one
is the head and then we have the body
head consists of the metadata like title
it also consists of script and study
types and body comprises mostly of the
content of the web page so in this
example you can see a hedge fund which
is a heading tag you also have another
element which is the list element that
you can see which is an unordered list
which consists of two list items now
these two list items or the child
elements of this particular unordered
list and these two comprises of the
child element of body which in turn is
the child of the root HTML parent
development so we have a parent and
child relationship that you can see over
here
and when we speak about events later in
the modules so you can see like how the
parent can handle the child event or the
child can be able to
manipulate the events of the parent
element by a JavaScript
so we can use JavaScript to perform
different tasks of Dom manipulation like
traversing the term you can read the uh
text or the HTML text or in the text or
whatever property value which is present
in the form of the element inside the
element or a node so you can do a read
operation basically or you also can edit
or update something
and you also can add new elements we can
delete the existing ones we can change
the style so we can do all these
manipulation of this document object
model using just JavaScript
so all of the properties and methods and
whatever events that we have
available for manipulating and creating
pages and these are organized into
something like objects
so the document object that represents
the document itself the table object
that implements the special HTML table
element Dom interface for accessing HTML
tables and so forth
so the entire Dom if you see it's like
object reference object by object
reference
so what is the power of JavaScript in
manipulating this Dom so we'll see the
perspective of JavaScript now so using
JavaScript as I told earlier so you can
add elements or nodes or you also can
remove the HTML elements or nodes that
we see in the structure but this is just
not HTML elements of the content
even you can manipulate the style
so you know cascading style sheet or
this CSS
which represents the theme of a page so
for a web page the theme or style is
very very important so the HTML
represents the content and CSS
represents the style or theme
and the JavaScript is the core
functionality of the feature of a web
page so these three things are like you
know like eternity of a web page or
website these three things complement
each other and go hand in hand so just
with your JavaScript so your content is
definitely important uh content is King
for any particular website or system so
content is mandated it has to be there
so without content it's nothing but
style is also very important so if you
have to attract your first time
customers so you can attract them only
with a very nicely styled team or design
so this UI and ux design is plays a very
important role to attract your customers
so after attracting your customers so
these are just not enough it is also
important to provide good features so
your customers now trying to shop from
your website so here is so attracted by
your design minimalistic beautiful
design so he starts shopping
and after that at some point or the
other he is unable to put items in the
cart or he is not able to contact you
via some contact form so these are
provided by your JavaScript or some
JavaScript packages like jQuery or
angular or react so this is very very
important so the functionality and
feature if you don't provide it of
course the customer you're going to lose
your customer
so your JavaScript is so important and
Powerful here that um so I was saying
that using your JavaScript you can add
whole lot of HTML content you can from
scratch you can add Styles also or
change the existing Style
and not just the font and color
um you also can completely change the
spacing padding alignment everything so
the entire theme style and content you
can change via JavaScript alone and
coming back to your
events now this is very important part
of JavaScript
this is the place where the user
interacts with that web page or website
say for example in the form of a
form so you have a registration form or
a contact form
so using these forms so where we have
these input elements like a button we
also have lot of text boxes and check
boxes so all using all these input
elements so we can get the input and we
can interact with the user so the user
can click a button and he can select
something he can learn or he can get
into uh some particular input element
but by giving some Focus now all these
are done in the help of some triggering
points which is called as events
it is event listener especially for
older browsers and these events are
nothing but some triggering point which
can trigger some actions now these
actions are termed as functions or your
Handler for that particular event
so to put this in a very simple Layman
form say for example someone is ringing
the bell your doorbell and you're
getting up and you are attending the
tours you're opening the door and
checking who is it
so in this scenario so someone ringing
the bell is the event
and you getting up and going and seeing
so who is it and accordingly responding
so that would be the function so that is
the action so you that particular event
doorbell ringing has triggered you to do
or take some action which is your
function so we will see more about this
even so in this project I will have a
lot of parents and we will also be
handling those using some functions and
actions
so what next
here in our project so in this demo that
we will be seeing what are we going to
do so what is the takeaway so what can
you expect out of this so you can see
this screenshot so this is the web page
that you will be creating
now this webpage as I told you earlier
it is a movie website so it's like a
movie web page it's a single page that
we are going to create and you can see a
list of movies to watch some latest
movie so you also have some red color
buttons to your right
so these buttons like uh so here it is
written as delete button and there is
also a green color add button over there
which is at the end of the page where
you can input some movie name and you
can dynamically add it now all these we
are doing via JavaScript so you can
statically add it also using your HTML
but in this particular example so we are
going to use JavaScript to dynamically
add a new movie and if you want to
delete those movie we are going to
delete that also so this is what we are
going to see as an example and in this
demo application so wherein you can
create these uh details of the movies
now I have to say something here so I
have started this using CSS
but it will not be going in depth into
the CSS because that is not enough scope
but I will walk you through the code
that I have written so that you get this
beautiful you know the background image
and the alignment and margin and padding
those are the properties that I have
included to get this style so I will
walk you through that then once that is
done so we'll focus more on our
JavaScript code so that we can create
this particular
movie website in an easier so very very
simpler easier manner so how we can
implement this particular
concept of Dom manipulation so that we
will be seeing in our movie Project okay
so let's get started
and before we begin with the actual
coding
of creating a new movie and deleting a
movie so before we do that I would like
to walk you through the
um actual application
so let's get started on that
so before we get on to the coding and
stuff so I would like you to take a look
at the final web page or the website
that you would be creating
so let's take a look at that now so this
will be the
um website that you will be uh
developing so you can see that it's a
movie web page it's it's kind of a
single page uh application because we
are creating just one single uh webpage
for this particular demo so you can
create any number of pages you want
later but for this we are just going to
create one index.html now in this if you
can see there is a list of movies here
popular movies
yeah so most of my favorites that you
can see and as I move my cursor you can
see that there is a purple color
um like a border that's actually a
border that I have written in uh CSS
it's a border property so you can see
that on the left which is highlighting
that particular row and you also can see
a corresponding button in red which is
the delete button so when I press it's
going to delete that particular movie
and you also can see a text box at the
end of this page and there is a green
color button to add a new movie for this
so you can see the entire page has been
styled in CSS so it looks quite
appealing so I have given an image which
emulates like a movie screen movie
theater screen and there is a card that
you can see so this is the card and so
which has this title and a tagline and
all these have been aesthetically
arranged here as you can see so this lot
of CSS here so which goes about to
create the theme and style of any web
page so CSS is very very important so if
you have to attract any um
no probable customer for your page or
for your business the that something
that is very important The Entity that
is very important is your style or your
theme so the CSS plays a major role over
here so I will show you the um you know
I will have a Code walkthrough of how I
have styled using CSS so let's try to
add a movie over here you also can see
there is a
um placeholder tip also text also over
there
um
let's go on with this movie
yeah the popular one so let's say add
and you can see instantly now uh
Avengers getting added at the end of
this particular row and you also can see
that there is a delete button that got
added automatically so if I have to
delete a movie
so you can see that it just goes off
instantly and I have to remind you
um so this is not a link to any database
so it's not persistently stored so if I
have to refresh it you get everything
back so this is just like stored in an
array so it's just a list of movies that
we are just going to store in the page
so if you have to have these changes
reflected of course you'll have to
connect it to a database so this is what
we are going to do
um so using the Dom and using the
JavaScript feature so how are we going
to add an entity or element to your Dom
and how are we going to delete it
this is what you can expect out of this
demo all right so here we are in the
editor
I'm using visual studio code so this is
the editor that I'm using currently
I do use other editors like Sublime
brackets webstorm so this is purely up
to you whichever is the editor that
you're comfortable with and you're
already working even if it is going to
be notepad plus plus
or if you are from a Java background and
you use Eclipse more you can go ahead
with eclipse so whatever is your editor
your prefer Preferred Choice uh you can
go with that Visual Studio code have
been working since the Inception so I
have I'm also from the dotnet background
so I've worked exhaustively with the
visual studio also
so here this editor is very comfortable
in many ways it is just not for
JavaScript it you also can use vs code
for angular or react or python any other
type of technology that you choose any
type of web development you can use
visual studio so it has a very nice
intuitive and simple user interface and
it has an integrated terminal so where
you can run your server also and it has
a very good debugging options with
intellisense and you can install
packages on the go and you can also use
this particular space for deployment
also so it's pretty
um easy and comfortable
so if you prefer visual studio and you
are from that background or you have
been using exhaustively for mean stack
command stack so you can use Visual
Studio otherwise it's completely up to
your choice so you can see that I have a
folder
which is called as Dom demo where I
already have three files there so two of
which is nothing but some pictures so
this is the background so that I'll be
using so if you could recollect so I
have shown you the uh web page with that
theater background so I will be using
these two images for that so you can
take a look at it so you can see this
one right you could recollect that so I
will be using this for background and
where I will be listing out the movies
so I will be using this image I will not
be using the entire image I will be
cropping and I will be using it
and the all these style uh to use these
images for other style features also for
including those buttons and you know the
rows all these I have used CSS cascading
style sheet and so this is the style
that I will be including so so I will
not be
um you know explaining each and
everything so I presume so you all have
some basic knowledge of CSS and HTML
um so what I have done briefly to get
that style I will explain it
in a very
um
precise concise manner so that like you
will get an idea like where what feature
I have included and you can explore on
your own these style features
so you can see that the background image
I have added as this property and the
size font family and colors and spacing
you have set this is for the heading and
so you should be knowing about different
types of selectors like ID selectors tag
selector class selector so this hash
denotes the ID selector
so I will be using this ID selector when
I'm creating my HTML page so what I have
done is for that particular I'm creating
one container okay so for that container
I'm giving a name called as wrapper so
where this container is the one which is
going to list out all the movies for us
so the margin padding border now these
are very very important so if you want
to have a evenly aligned a readable
legible list or text or content so you
have to play around with these different
properties of CSS
and you also can see that um
there is a page Banner so this is the
outermost container then I will also be
showing an image within that where the
movie list will be displayed and within
that I will be giving the you know the
top movies that list so for that and the
paragraph or the tagline so some of
these alignment features and width and
margin I have given so you also can see
that I have given certain elements with
these IDs movie list and this is for the
button add movie
margin has been given there and the list
I do it's an unordered list so unordered
list
um I don't want to specify any
particular bullets there so ordered list
will be having like one two three or
ABCD unordered usually bullets will be
displayed so I don't want any bullets so
I am displaying that as null
and so this is the one
um I have used for the list items that
you can see and by default if I don't
move the cursor the Border left if you
can recollect I had one purple color one
right which got highlighted only on the
left border
um so by default I have made it as you
know gray so but when I hover the so
this is the pseudo uh list so when I
hover over it so the state it gets
changed so it becomes the color becomes
purple here and these are the style
features that you can see for the delete
button so this is the delete button so
it's a class so that's why it has this
period symbol and so what are the
difference so it has a radius it has a
rounded Corners that button and the text
is white so all these and again like
when I hover so from Red it changes the
background color
and you also can see
um this is the style for the add movie
button you can see that so this is
predominantly it isn't
um gray color and so this is for the
input which is your text box and this
this is the add movie button so this
particular
button so I have made it as green and
you can see the other features also and
again so however it becomes like a dark
green so these things and all you can
change right and for these labels so for
all the elements that I will be creating
now in the index.html so this is the
style that I'm going to apply so you can
go ahead with your own style there is no
restriction so you can change the color
the alignment you want to change the um
the background layout so completely up
to you so our focus is not CSS for this
particular demo so our focus is on the
javascript's done manipulation
all right so let's start creating our
web page so the first step how do we
create our web page is by creating a
HTML page
um after we create a HTML page and set
those content you know the list of
movies
we'll try to create uh the most
important file which is your JavaScript
file and we will connect all these
together to your HTML file so we already
have the Styles dot CSS in place
um so after we create our HTML page
we'll be creating the JavaScript page
also and we will be connecting all these
three together
so here you can see there is an icon
which states new file
and so let's get this name
index.html and you can see the icon gets
magically changed over there
um so I have a corresponding
uh you know uh extension file
which actually
gives all these extension the logos will
be automatically updated so you might
not be having that by default so if you
want you can just go ahead with your
these extensions you can see that so you
can see this this is the one that I have
already included PS code icons so if you
want to have those logos so that you
have a clear picture of what you're
creating
you will be able to do it so here we
also can create one more which is your
app.js this is the one that you will be
creating next
so you can see this JS icon also pops up
nicely so by default you might not be uh
seeing this icons but if you have that
particular extension that file you
should be able to see it all right so
inside my um
index dot HTML so let's start with our
coding so first thing so you can see
that very nicely this intelli sense is
also popping up
okay so here I say that it is a HTML5
document
so the HTML document earlier we had
html4 version for many many years so
recently it was upgraded
um w3c which is our world wide web
upgraded back to the next level which is
your HTML file so here this particular
the first line where it denotes the
namespace it's much more concise and
precise now otherwise if you know about
if you have already coded in html4 you
will know the pain of writing that you
know lines and lines of that namespace
so the first line indicates that it is a
HTML5 document so now we'll have to
specify the root element or the parent
element of the outermost one which is
our HTML so all our tags and elements
goes inside this
HTML tag
so we have this head and we also have
the body
so
so head as I told you earlier during the
discussion so where I was saying that
all the metadata and other
properties like your title and so if you
want to link other files like your
Styles or your script everything goes
inside your head having said that you
also can include your script SRC
anywhere inside your body also you can
have more than one script Source also
not necessarily that it has to be inside
your head only
but we specify some metadata and other
um within your head elements so here I'm
including one character set here so this
is the default one which is your unicode
okay hey
so not mandatory but you can include
this one and as I told you we can also
include your style and you also can
include your script but we'll do that
later so right now I'll just include my
title so which will be displayed on the
web page title bar on the uh topmost one
that you can see I will say
movie time
right so now this goes inside the head
as it
while we were going through this style
so we have already created this
outermost container and I have given
some name for that so we will be using
this in our HTML
content so where I'm going to create a
dip
and all the ID so will be represented as
hash that you will be using in your CSS
so you can see this one so have used
this hash it means that we'll have to
use an ID over here so let's say
wrapper
now this is going to be my outermost dip
and all leather elements are going to be
present inside this div
and inside my div I'm going to have a
header so this is a HTML element header
and inside this header I'm going to have
the title
so which says movie time and it also has
a tagline I showed you in the finished
web page
so those movie title as well as the
tagline I'm going to include it here so
inside my header I'm going to have this
one more div and I've already created
the style for this
so this will be the page Banner
and inside my page Banner
I'm going to have this title so the
movie title I'm going to use H1 over
here
and
I'm also giving the class because I've
already defined and you also can Define
the style outside or you can have a
style inside the head that you can refer
so in that case it could be referred as
internal style now this will be external
style but if you want you can also have
an inline Style say for example
I can include a style property here so
this will become the inline style of H1
which will have the highest residence
so in this I say I want to have a white
color
so you can either pick from the text as
such or you also can give this hex value
so both are same
then after that so all your CSS
properties are terminated by a semicolon
and it uh it's separated with this colon
like this property name and the value
separated by colon and the statement it
ends with the semicolon
so here you specify whatever is the
heading that you wish to display
and
next we will be giving the tagline
so let's also have an inline element for
the tagline
so we'll be using the same thing which
is the white text since we are going to
have a colored background
so we are using the white text here so
I'm copying and pasting it here
so here so we'll have to close this
here let's say
um
accurated
stuff most amazing
movies
so you can write your text like how
about when you want so however you want
to
display those taglines and the title
so I'm closing my paragraph here and I'm
also giving a break there
and so with this this particular div
which is the page Banner so this is over
so I've created this page Banner just to
display this is the entire thing is your
header you can see so this is your
which is your banner and this entire
thing is my wrapper so I I still have my
list of movies that will be coming up
here in this section so this will be the
title And the tagline
so after this header I want to include a
tab
which is going to be my movie list
so we'll call this movie
second list
and inside which I'm going to
have
um
the title again something like a
subtitle
so I'm using my um
H2 so where I say again I get this title
class so which will be used in styling
and
within which I will say these two words
so this will be the title for the list
so after which we are going to include
our unordered list of movies
now inside pitch inside the unordered
list I'm going to have now see two
things here
um
if you could recollect the uh the movie
page that I had shown
we will be creating the name of the
movie in the in a row voice format and
it will also be having the uh delete
button so you would be able to see that
the delete button would be there and uh
so both elements have to be there for
each movie list so I will be specifying
the name of the movie here
and I will also be specifying the uh
delete button so inside my list item I'm
going to have a span
now this span so I'll say
that will have name
and
where let's include the first run
and run and I will be including a span
element policy
delete button also
and I will just say delete
okay
so let me copy this one because we are
just going to use this for all the this
particular style for all or movies so
I'm copying this and I'm pasting uh
maybe four or five movies
so
three
three four and five
okay so let's um
write whatever movies that you want over
here so let me just change these movies
quickly
okay so all of my favorite movies
Inception again
yeah and
stage
okay
all right so the last one maybe I have
included one extra chicken
um
just the Avengers Avengers okay whatever
so I have uh included this five movies
now so with this this movie list is over
so now next what we will do is we'll
have to do one more thing before we move
on to JavaScript file so in this one we
have to create
are
we will be having a form element here
the main reason being we have to include
uh submit button so that
I can inform the JavaScript module or
the function so which can handle the
addition of new movie when I have to
click on the add button here
so I'm giving a name for the ID so this
will be the form so which will be the
parent element and inside the form I'm
going to
um what we are going to have is we are
going to have the button and also the
input box
so the input
the text box we will be including so you
can see the list of
input elements of your HTML so we'll be
selecting test
and we can have a placeholder it's
nothing but the text
okay
so where I can specify okay so this is
this should not be inside
this is text
so the placeholder property where you
can give some hint of what is supposed
to be entered in that text box so I'll
say add um
[Music]
so let's close this input box
now this button let's add so now this is
going to invoke the function which we
will be adding in the JavaScript
page
so with this uh we have closed this form
and we have also closed this div and the
body so with this the HTML content the
code for the HTML content is ready
you have to see this page so I have this
option set up here so open in default
browser
so when I click this one
okay so you can see this and so if
you're wondering why is this blank over
here
um
you can see this here now yeah it's the
main reason is I've given white text
because we'll have to include this style
we have not included the style yet so
just the HTML content it looks like this
so it's not it doesn't look so great I
know
um so there is no JavaScript function
also but we can see that whatever
content that we have mentioned so it has
been displayed properly so the next step
for us to do is to add pcss and see if
it matches the style that I had shown
earlier
so if you have to add the CSS so let's
see okay so we have now seen before
adding PS2 so I keep saying about the
importance of the style and theme also
so I know your content is ready but it
doesn't look so attractive so how could
you make it so engaging and so that the
probable customer or your business user
can start using your web page so how can
you make it much more engaging and
attractive
let's add the CSS and see
If it creates a magic or not I know this
is not our Prime Focus but CS is
definitely helps so the link is the
um tag that we will be
using to specify the reference so this
is the reference where I have to add so
whatever is your CSS style so this is a
external style so I use my href property
to attach this external style here so
I'll have to include so you can see that
it gets listed yes
and um it's not mandatory but still you
can mention
that it is a style sheet
so CSS is the default style sheet and
JavaScript is the default
scripting language for your HTML so we
have attached this now okay so let us
see again
okay look at that now look at that so
you can see this before CSS
so
literally it is nothing it doesn't look
like anything at all but you can see
like after CSS so if you are if you have
uh fancy taking for your pawns if you
love pawns maybe you can change all
these fonts I've used some default fonts
um so however you want you can go ahead
and change it you can see that whatever
we have given in the CSS that I've
highlighted it's now getting reflected
in this new page so you can see the
difference between this and this so
that's why I open another tab for you to
show the see the difference but nothing
is going to work so you can see that the
hover so you can see the redist engine
into my room and this maybe not much of
a difference but you still can see I
would say if you're using CSS don't
change those uh text size and you know
the alignment and placing because
there the effect that you will be
getting where it will be like flickering
a lot and it will be the alignment will
be an issue always change the color or
some highlight those thing not the size
and Alignment so you can also see like
how nicely these rows are getting
highlighted
so now whatever we add so nothing is
going to be coming on because we don't
have a JavaScript functionality yet so
that is what we are going to see now
next so let's start
our JavaScript coding which will be the
next module now let's start with the
app.js which will be your Javascript
file that you will be including and
coding for Dom manipulation
so this app.js file has to be integrated
inside your
index.html so how we have included our
style we will have to use another
element which is your script and we have
to include SRC instead of href so that
we will do it later so now let's start
creating this code for the app.js
so let's start with this document
element and we will have to do the
coding for
uh one of the event so we'll be writing
those functionality whatever we have
done so we are going to create the event
and attach your
functionality for that particular event
so there are ways different ways by
which you can do it and eventh listener
is one of the way so I can specify so as
you can see in this entirely sense this
purple color box indicates that it is a
method so you can see that it is a
method and this blue brick that you see
so that is a property so we'll be using
this method
so adding an event over here so what is
the event that we are going to add now
so we are adding this
um event which is called as the Dom so I
will explain so what exactly is this Dom
content loaded now this event fires when
the initial HTML document has been
completely loaded and passed so without
for other dependencies like your CSS
file style sheets images or any other
elements to finish loading so your
original content so if it is loaded and
passed this event will be fired and the
target for this event is your document
itself and that has to be loaded and you
can listen for this event on the window
interface to handle it in the capturing
bubbling or the downloading phase so
JavaScript event has different type of
phases also
when the event can Traverse
inside from your parent to your child so
that it can be handled at that level
also it's called as your tunneling and
when it has to go upwards so it'll be
like bubbling phase so so different ways
by how your event can Traverse and it
can be captured
so there is another event which is
called as load now that will be you will
not be using that for this particular
purpose so here I'm just using this
event
to check if the content if that
particular document your HTML document
is loaded without the other dependencies
that's what I said without the style
sheet or other pictures to be loaded but
another event is there which is called
as just load and it should be used to uh
to take to detect a fully loaded page
along with stylesheet and everything so
it's usually people confused between
this load and the document content
included so understand the difference
for load it is like fully loaded whereas
Dom content loaded is only when the Dom
features or the HTML content is loaded
so let's write the function for this so
we will be using this syntax so first is
this event name and here we are going to
include the function so all other
function that we will be including so it
will be going inside this main function
that I have
first thing that I'm going to do is
create a variable in this case we will
be creating a constant because we are
not going to change anything to capture
where exactly these um event and the
functions will be affected so in our
case the list movie list is where we are
concerned we can add a movie we can
delete the movie so we have to create a
entity which can refer to that
particular list so I'm creating so you
can use a bar also here since this is
not going to be uh changing so I'm using
a constant so I'm using this method
which is called as your query selector
by which you can select that particular
um you know the element whatever element
that you have created so here I want to
select my unordered list so I'm using
this movie so it is present inside
um
container which is called as your movie
list so inside which I am selecting this
unordered list and that is getting
stored in this list so this is um it's
like
disabled or like grayed out because we
have not used this list object yet so
when we use it so it will be highlighted
I'm also going to create one more to
store my form
so whatever problems you can have like
multiple forms also and all the form
elements I'm storing here
and so let's do the first one say if I
have to delete my movies so to delete
this movie
I'm going to attach so we have already
created that list so to that list now I
told you right so now if you start using
it it will be highlighted so you can see
that one so I'm adding another event
listener so whenever I'm going to click
that uh I'm going to check if the user
is clicking the uh delete button or he's
clicking something else so I'm using
this
click event
so I'm attaching a event
an event handler I'm attaching over here
and then I am also
you can also pass on another parameter
so in this case I'm passing some e
parameter which is you can also name it
as event also
um for whatever name that you want so
this even parameter is nothing but all
the metadata will be stored in that
particular
um object e or the event object so it
will have all the necessary properties
stored there so you can find out the
source of the event you can find out the
target of even so everything will be
stored in the event object so here I'm
checking using my if condition so I'm
checking if the target okay so if the
target element has I told you the event
object will have the source where it
originated and which is the target so
here I'm checking if the class name is
equal to is equal to delete meaning if
I'm trying to click on the delete button
I'm checking that so if it is right so
if it is true then I am creating
um a light
which is your list item and I'm trying
to remove that particular element there
so I am saying the target so I'm saying
which is the pair see when I have to
delete the element it has to delete the
entire Li right including the span which
is the movie text also one more span
which has the delete button so I have to
delete the parent element
so here I'm mentioning that I'm creating
the LI which is the parent element and
now I say the parent node of this
particular Li so I want to delete this
so to delete an entity in Dom if you
have to do it you have an
uh method which is called as your remote
charge so you can see that
so the parent node along with your so
both your spam so the entire Li element
I have to remove so I am removing it
like this I am calling this method which
is called as your remote child which is
going to remove that particular Li
element
so now this is with your
Li so here we have added this and we are
trying to delete it
so this is one of the functionality and
the next one that we have to do is add
movies
so before adding the movie so let's see
if this is going to really work so for
that we have to include one more step
what is that
yes right we have to attach it so your
index.html does not have this
app.js linked yet so let's add that so
here we'll be using script SRC
is equal to so this is my app.js and
let's include this one
so once you have included
um so in my app.js I have given the main
Dom content loaded event so underneath I
have these different features included
one is the deleting the movie one is
deleting the movie another one that we
will be writing is adding the movie so
let's see if this is going to work or
not so go back to this
I've already added the script and so you
can open it so or you can refresh the
existing page also let us see if the
delete button really works now
yes it works
so
okay I just deleted everything but as I
told you earlier
this is
um
this is not a permanent database that
you will be like storing so these does
not get reflected persistent in a
persistent way
so when we refresh the page we are going
to get it back but we can see that the
deletion uh via Dom manipulation using
JavaScript code has worked successfully
now so we are done with the first
feature so we will have to move on to
the second one where we can add a new
movie and when we click on this button
it has to be instantly added let us go
back to the editor to add the next
feature now
so let's get started with adding the
new movie
so it's not like these straightforward
delete feature there are certain series
of steps that is involved
when we are adding a new movie
so first being to creating the elements
look whatever
elements that we are going to add so
it's just not one text or the movie list
we also have to add the delete button
along with that
right so that would be the first one and
the second one would be to add
the text content as such so what is the
text content or value what is the new
one so the delete text and also the name
of the movie so that has to be added and
you can see that each and every
[Music]
um
you know these it has a distinctive
style property the left a purple border
when it is highlighted and each row it
also has a delete which is like a red
color button which is curved on the
edges so these different style features
have to be included so how do we do that
so that would be another step that we
have to do which is adding the classes
and finally we will have to attach it to
the Dom so then you attach it to your
Dom element
so let's start with the first phase so
all these element now it's present in
the form so from the form we are trying
to add
um the new movie new element so for that
we'll have to capture the form so form
is in the form of an array so each HTML
element can have n number of forms so we
have already given the ID as ADD movie
or that form we just have one form so we
are retrieving that and I am storing it
inside my ad form constant
next
so I'm using this at form to add this
event listener over here
so when the button so which is so here
you can have all these events so here
I'm saying submit is the event so submit
is the most important event so by which
you can actually support the value
otherwise
um whatever changes that needs to be
captured will not be done properly so
I'm including this function
and again I'm passing this event object
which is your e
so now here
um I'm adding all these ones so first
one that I'm doing over here is to
include your
ribbon
default this prevent default method
cancels the event
if it is cancelable meaning that the
default action that the
that belongs to the event will not occur
um say for instance if we have to use it
um for uh when the user clicks on a
submit button but it has to prevent that
clicking or submitting of a form or
there is a clicking on a hyperlink or
something but it should be prevented so
these default actions now if you want to
prevent uh so you can use this one so
here we are going to use it because we
don't want this to be
literally
bubbled up and but you also have to note
that not all events are cancelable you
can use the cancelable property to find
out if some event is cancelable or not
and these this particular proven default
method also does not prevent further
propagation of an event through the
launch so if you want to literally stop
it so there is another method which is
called a stop propagation
so
we are invoking this method first and so
let me just close this one also and I
want all these other feature to be
included within this one
okay
so first step after creating the uh
capturing the form element
I want to create the other constants for
these values and elements the other
elements so first thing I am creating a
constant called as a value
now here I am selecting D using the
query selector again this method again
and I want to retrieve this input type
so where I say
my text box so I want to retrieve it so
where I say the
type as
text so
I want to retrieve the input type where
the type is
there so be very careful with the course
so if you are using the double quotes as
the outer ones just use it for that and
use an inner for the inner code user
single code so vice versa so check on
that and how it is closing
so otherwise it will not throw any error
but you will not be getting the value
that you expect also and the second
constant that I want to create it is for
the list item so here I have the
document and here we are going to use
this special method you can see that
there are so many number of create
element create even many create methods
are there as a part of JavaScript Dom
feature
so we are going to use this one create
element and I'm going to create a new Li
element because this is the one that we
want which needs to be added to the
unordered list
and of course we will have to create the
um
the corresponding variable or the
constant for the name of the movie so
that has to be there right so I'll have
to create that one so that one again is
as you can see it's a spam so I'll show
you the HTML code here so quickly let's
go and so you can see this once this is
what we are trying to create here in
this feature so I will have to create
two elements over here so one is for the
movie another spam is for the delete
button so these two has to be created so
this is a span and you can see that the
class will have to add next but this Li
element we have to create it like this
that is what we are doing here
so I am creating a span so one is for
the movie name and another one we have
to create a delete button
so if we have to create a new record so
each record has a movie name as well as
the delete button so I'm going to create
that as well
so in this one again so what is the
element that we will be creating in both
the cases both are span which is present
inside and light so Ally is the parent
element and these two span will be the
child element so all these have been now
created uh individually or separately we
have created now we have to set the
hierarchy so we have to append these two
as child office Li and this Li has to be
attached to this
body so this one so this appending will
do to the last right so first step we
have created this elements so first we
have retrieved the movie and we have
added attached event listener for the
submit button and um and then in the
second one second phase of creating
elements we have created so we have
checked if whatever is the value that
the user is entering inside the text box
so using that we are going to create it
so then we have created the LI element
which is your list item and then the
span element for the movie name span
element for the delete button so all
these have been created now let's go to
the next phase which is to add the text
content so we have already received the
value that the user has entered in the
text box and we are storing it in the
constant called as value so now that we
have to attach it to this particular
element which is the movie name okay so
that will be the next one so here I will
say movie name dot so it has this
property as you can see which is called
as the text content so so this is the
span element so if you have to create a
text for that so I'm saying that
whatever the user has entered in the
text box that is stored in the value
constant so that I am storing it here
that I am passing to my text content
property of the movie name which is
nothing but this fan that we have
created
now the second one we have also created
this delete button span right so that so
content we have to create so which is
nothing but the text that will be
displayed so here we are creating the
button as delete button
okay so however you want to create it
remove or the D caps however you want to
create you can go ahead and create it
so
now this step is also over so first we
have created this form and then we have
created all these elements uh the
corresponding Li and then the movie
names and delete button span and then we
have also attached the corresponding
content for these two span elements now
we have to add the style so of course
you can see like how it is displayed so
this one has a red color buttons and
then you can see the different
these borders so that we have already
created in the external style sheet this
has to be updated here
so we are doing this
so I say class list
dot add so this is ADD so we are adding
the class name
for the corresponding element that we
have created so that you get the style
feature
that we have already defined
okay by default it goes on with your ad
event listener
um all right so this is this is the
class name
so we are adding it so let's go to the
style dot CSS
and so you can see this delete
and name so all these are present over
here
right so all these are there so I want
to attach so you can see this one name
and delete it already has this one so
that we are trying to attach it here so
this step is also over so we are
attaching the class for the style or the
team box
now final and most important one is to
attach it to the Doms so that all your
content along all your elements along
with those textual content added with
those class properties with the CSS
features now it is all rendered onto
your Dom in a proper hierarchical way so
that is now is very important so that is
the final step
so I am saying l i so now Li is your
parent element right so I'm attaching my
ni
first your Li has to be attached to the
list
I think they have already created this
list which is nothing but the unordered
list so this Li has to be attached to
the list and
inside your Li these two uh spans your
movie name and delete button both has to
be attached so your movie name and
delete button are the child elements of
Li and Li is the child element of your
list so it has to be attached so first
let's let's attach your um
movie name so the child of your
Ally which is the first span and I'm
also attaching the
delete
button so which is another span child
and finally I'm attaching the Li
which is in turn a child or the list
element
okay so here I say list dot a French
child which is your ally
okay but inside your Li you can see the
movie name and delete button we can go
to the index.html project so UL or the
list is the parent element inside which
I have my l i list item and the LI is it
becomes the parent for these two which
is the name of the movie and the delete
button for each corresponding record so
these two child element first we are
attaching to a line and then this Li we
are attaching is to the UI so that is
what we are doing here
right so this will be the final and most
important step so with this we are done
with our
script
so make sure you save this one
and let's go back to this
and refresh it once
okay so this delete button it is working
as usual
we have already seen that and let's see
if a new movie can be inserted
okay let's say
wow now you can see that instantly uh
new movie has been added at the bottom
and you can see the two span elements
okay which is the child of the zli it
gets added to the uh parent which is the
list item so this is the outermost one
which is the
UL or your list type list and then each
one is the child which is your life the
LI has two child which is your movie
name as well as the delete button so we
have first created these values and then
the classes have been added to ensure
that the CSS is consistent and then
finally we use the Dom's append child
you can use your append method also to
attach it so that this hierarchy is
formed so using Dom manipulation via
JavaScript so we have seen that as a
very very
um
powerful in a very in a powerful way and
in a very simpler and effective way how
we can add new elements new nodes attach
events listen to events and also to
delete it all these it can be done so
effectively so you can keep adding
or you can try to validate this also and
say if I want to edit this I won't edit
the existing movies even that it is
completely possible you can do that or
only the style if you want you can
change that style also so everything
just with JavaScript so just with
JavaScript so how you can create the
elements so without the HTML content at
all you can just like right from the
heading to the footer to the content
everything you can create just with your
JavaScript so that is the power of
JavaScript so I think we have done quite
enough with this manipulation so for a
quick recap
um we started with these three files so
style dot CSS so I walked you through
the entire style and theme features I
have Incorporated and we also had these
two images already so you can include so
this is just an overview uh guideline of
how this Dom can be manipulated in one
way you are free to explore having this
as a base and you can just work upon how
you want to carry on with your Dom
manipulation so we created first this
index.html so we created all the content
the head and body and initially we
didn't attach it with the style sheet as
well as the script
then we created those containers the
wrapper run page Banner so that we had
the corresponding styles for all these
and we also created a
UL which is an unordered list with all
these list items so these list item
internally so it has each one had two
span one is the name of the movie
another one is the delete button for the
movie and you also
um can see that last we have also added
an input element for the text box where
you can add the movie and also a button
to submit so that the new movie has been
inserted so after this we created this
JavaScript coding so we started with the
Dom content loaded and first we saw the
delete movie uh we use the event
listener when whenever I click on the
delete button so based on the event
object I checked for the Target and I'm
removing that particular element so I'm
using the remote child over here for
deleting a movie or deleting any
particular note as such and we are using
um
so these two are the important functions
that you have to keep in mind and in the
second one we added a movie first we
created this form we captured this and
then we created those individual
elements the LI span for the movie name
and delete button and we also had those
values that needs to be written which
was added and then we added the class
and finally we use the app and child to
append these two span element to the Li
and then Li which is the child of your
list gets added so that is how we saw
this Dom manipulation so
I hope you all enjoyed this uh demo and
also your uh the concept of your Dom
manipulation via JavaScript is clear to
all of you if getting your learning
started is half the battle what if you
could do that for free visit scale up by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more
in JavaScript we'll first create some
simple beginner level projects like the
to-do list app
then we'll move on to a quiz app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app the tic-tac-toe
game and finally we'll conclude the
session by creating a snake game
application
now I'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin
using this JavaScript CSS and HTML combo
mode is called TD application to do
application kind of Journal Task Manager
application where you can attach at the
task delete the task and complete the
task very simple and so constipated
application we will try to start working
with and here you start working with our
first very simple statement that this
one is called tutorial
not good
[Music]
let's see the studio I like to start
working with external file index Dot
HTML
and now here
again we would like to start working
with the HTML by considering our thesis
I will be well taken care of so we say
okay sorry
okay
we will see Clause equal to
continue
now inside this we would like to have
some Hello portion okay so we say
another
and insert a stick type let's say did ID
equal to
this box
okay and again
class equal to
plus equal to
now here after that
we'll go to use the http
and inside I can see
why
to do list
or to the fetch tool we like to use the
text box
input
input at the blue text
ID equal to
item and
please hold it equal to give anything
and say
title
okay on the close this
next we like to use a sprinter
conflict
equal to
now
I do not have the function link or new
element but you would have to create it
okay and
plus equal to
all right
okay and here I would like to
okay that's my spine type now
Dev talk is also getting closed
so after the drift type you would like
to use the viewer
you know that you found another list
here I will say ID equal to
I'm going to see what that I look for
array and within the setup you can say
something
hello
[Music]
tasks
is the first item like that I can have
some other items with me
great news
talk with the dog like that I can have n
number of tasks which is available
that's it okay so I do not have any CSS
file with me so I can just create
census in this I would like to input it
in more here
to install shift href equal to the name
that's it let me try to see the outcome
okay so I can have
very simple we can feel for title
nothing is there add
which must be a kind of a button for me
or whatever it is so it is just a span
type for me on which I will try to click
and perform some action so remember it
is not available
[Music]
so my thesis
uh we want to basically perform the
addict where close button I want to
create it and I want to create a close
button to hide the current list items in
multiple activities I have it which I
want to do it with my CSS let's get
started with CSS now and with my CSS I
would like to create some basic effects
toward my application
fine so the step number one I would like
to say asterisk
for everything that means for everyone
I'm saying box sizing
border box
basically
nothing is affected because it's so
common for all
here I would like to start with my body
now
body
background color
background color I will say lights to
the blue
light go up take it and background image
it's up to me whether I would like to
use it or not what I can use
height 600 pixels
next background position
that I would like to use Center
Nexus pattern repeat
because if I do not have any reach I
would not be using repeat so
background size
cover
looks beautiful well going ahead we'll
talk about our containing part
okay so if I just see my previous code
which is there with me that is called
calculator app
here in this app.css
our option called container
so therefore we continue I just copy
this
and I use it again here
here and continue with I would like to
use fifty percent now
background color remain white align self
Center display block margin
disturb using
130 pixels
Auto and box Shadow border it is you're
not using
padding once again
[Music]
box Shadow 5 pixel 10 pixel 50 pixels
right perfect
there we go
okay
so this is my simple look now talk about
the UL partner
margin
next order left
cases
t
next just
iPhone style iPhone type
I'm saying none
next party
better
okay now
so
few things have used
uh
model left 6 pixel solid T padding now
we talk about our URL Allied part
cursor
pointer
next position
relative
next pedal
we just would like to use four pixels
like this
background
White
smoke
okay font size
you can select 18 pixels
transition
for zero point
two seconds
for transition
okay and the last option
user I can select
no
perfect
now looks beautiful
you can see now how the effects are
awesome
okay URL like that now
we talk about our positions wise
properties you will
array colon
over
okay I said
background color
okay and after that I use evil
let's check
odd values
background color
again I can use the same
okay now
after this
we are using this called Uli project
and I'll be using background
then color
I'm using the same White
decoration
which is the checked option
okay now after that
check before I also want to use it so we
just say you will
check
before
you will like check column before
content
after that position
absolute
after that bottle Style watercolatory
bottle I'm just using call White
then model Style
solid
then bottle it
border iPhone width
but hyphen width variation zero
two pixels
zero
then talk
10 pixels
left
excels
then transform
rotate 45 degrees
then hide
15 pixels
then convert
something
now you see this now
how they look like
the JavaScript will be applied later on
to make it even more better so we are
just getting it ready for that
okay after that we'll be using for close
and this close using position
absolute
then right
zero
padding
four options we are using it here
okay there are tools
close
or
in this close over will be using
background color
that's called
origin
and color
White
this is for closer
then we're talking about color header
header Philippines in background color
then padding
pretty pixels
and 30 minutes
color
okay texture line
Center
looking beautiful
well this is your head robot we have
written it now after we've been talking
about positive after an input
Dot
header colon
content colon
and then display
table
after that
is for header after
okay now after this will be used for the
input
directly input
for input or input we have to make it
more better way margin
zero
then border
then border radius
zero
then bit
75 percent
then party
10 pixels
okay then float left
the next option will be font size
perfect
nice
so this is my text box
okay now we'd like to talk about call
buttons
okay
it's time to talk about code buttons
we'll be saying Dot
add
video
so once again the condition is going to
be remain same
docker
adding
pixels
talk about covert
we say 25 percent
it's a background
open
then we talk about call color
okay and we use float
left
after this fourth let me talk about
texturing
Center
then font size
16 pixels
to talk about cursor
could be pointer
we will talk about what transition
here we talk about 0.3 seconds
and then border radius
that's it
and at the same time we talked about
[Music]
to change to
English
that's it let's check
awesome
so you see now how exactly now
so my to-do list CSS part is over okay
well after this we're gonna talk about
our GS file which is the most important
area of your code now here if we closed
on everything
and start creating another file here on
this call
app.js the main calculation goes here
so from this point onwards we would like
to start working with our property
whichever we have to interact here on
the top of that will be start over here
okay
so in my CSS what are the things are
required
that we want to understand
my my list
equal to
document Dot
get element by ID or a service
and the tag name is what
all right let's call this titles
for I input 0
I is listed
load list
my notice Dot
length and then all
plus this
okay later on we will create our
equal to
document dot create element
document or create element which element
I want to create it
delete
spent everyone created after that you
are
fixed for a second server
txt equal to again
document dot create text node
and
I'll just give the value here I think
forward slash
so we create another new text
okay later on we just says Bank
dot class name
spine dot class name equal to
close
after that
bye
Dot
open J
txt
and then
my node list
all right
Dot
open chain
so the first function which we have
written
so there's the name
after that
what we need to do now is
um we have to start working with our
option called UR
close equal to
document
by classroom
get it in your classroom names for what
you see or
I
on the cross again
for
zero
is invested
close dot length
I press this
okay then
close
I
Dot
on
click
okay close I dot okay equal to
function
and now we save our
enter equal to this Dot
parent
store
and now effective
Dot
style Dot
display
okay
and now
next thing so this is for when you try
to click on the close button to hide the
current list item
okay we can say
current
first
okay now next what we could talk about
the code is is to basically add a check
sample okay while clicking on a list
item that means if any item that you
basically click so what should happen
now
so when I so it will get strike signal
hey this task is over now so you can say
over
list
document query selected
New York
okay let's see
oh
add events here
on which event on a click even and then
I need to write about function
which takes event as in parameter
okay here I see if
Dot
Target
class list
Dot
oh
dot toggle heroic checked
okay then what should happen now
but before that
I just need to check the condition for
if
dot Target dot tag name this way
go to target.
then what then
dot Target Dot
lastest Dot
toggle
okay
okay and here we pass the value code
that's it
okay now you have to basically go and
create what a functions for this
so after that I'm going to create a new
function now on same function
okay here we'll save our
hello
equal to document
Dot
create element
which is
input value equal to
document
Dot
get element by ID
item
Dot
okay and after that we just calculating
this value we are saying one
t
equal to
document dot create textbook
okay here we pass
input value here and I say array Dot
copied child of t
like this and here we are saying if
input value
equal to
blank nothing is there then what so in
such cases we can say alert
these are basically the validation for
me
alert
this field cannot be empty
okay this field cannot be empty so this
is the first edit position in the else
condition
in this condition it is a document
Dot
get element by ID
okay which is a type of item
so
okay
otherwise what would happen
we will talk about this option called
talking determined by ID item
item controlled value
equal to by
okay that's the case now after that it
will start working with our
span tag now the span tag will have its
own conditioner so first we check about
this and now we talk about diagram so
you just say for this fan you say or
or span equal to
document Dot
foreign
yeah so we're not talking about Culver
txt
equal to once again document
dot create textbook
we talk about you
sir
after span
Dot
option
to extreme
okay and then save my video using delay
Dot open child
dot open child
and then last but not least we have to
basically write it through all
four
I equal to 0
I is less than
close Dot
length and
I
plus plus
then
close of type I we are passing it dot
one click equal to
function
and here we are saying work
div equal to this stop
parent element
okay and div for
style Dot
screen equal to
so so friends we are almost ready now
because our JavaScript file is ready
after that we'll be talking about how to
include it in HTML to take a look well
everybody so we are all safe now since
we have our application ready with me
Jesus is building round number
index.html5 you have to just check
how to apply this GS within my code now
so in my index.html file I'll just go to
my the bottom of my page that is called
Script
script SRC
equal to
the name or approaches
that's it
okay and let's check about my final
outcome
okay so you can see now the crossbar
automatically appeared okay with my
application let me try to add another
one that is called
Ubuntu see it is
called strike that means it is done if I
try to click on this it goes off if I
click it here strike with click here
add another
it's also working
deleted
click it again it is uncheck or unstripe
so guys that's it so
we are happy like finally we have
finished one of our very important
project which is equal to do application
okay so this time we're gonna develop
another very interesting example using
this HTML JavaScript and CSS together
and that is called working with a quiz
application so one of the very very
interesting projects will be developing
it from the scratcher I'm sure that you
will enjoy a lot
so what we will do we'll start creating
a new folder now first of all I'm going
to keep the name call
HTML quiz
now I'm going to create a three files
inside this number one I'm going to say
index.html
index.html then I need another file that
is called app.css
and the third file I'm going to create
an inside this that will hold the script
related part so we are saying script
torches
so we have total number of three files
ready with us now from HTML page we
would like to develop this HTML tags
first
so we'll go to the HTML and see
so we have got this basic HTML syntax
ready and from here we will start
working with the Dev tag first
here onwards Dev tag
so visit my tab tag we would like to
create another div tag
okay so the first top level class
through this particular tip see we
haven't created a CSS but we would like
to offer some of the CSS classes
available here so you see depth class
equal to container
now we have got another div track inside
this we will say div
IDE ID equal to question hyphen
container
question iPhone
container so that is the name or ID of
this tip and we say class
equal to height
now within this div tag we would like to
offer some details
but before that we would like to create
some embedded Dev tags inside this so
we're going to create another tip tag
here
and this tip ID
equal to
answer
hyphen buttons
so that's ID name and we would like to
offer the class also
class equal to
BTN hyphen grid see again I'm telling
you these classes you're just creating
it but we would like to use this in our
CSS okay so they are just the normal
classrooms we are giving it right now
inside this Dev tag
we want to offer
some more details
now what exactly the details are number
one if you'd like to offer few buttons
now
button so we see a button class
equal to BTN
and after that you would like to give
the name call answer one
answer one so that I can have this
button class
copied three more times
and now we can change the names to
here three
here four so we have total number of
four answers ready with us Dev tag is
getting closer another tip tag is
getting closed here and now here before
the last step tag is getting close we
would like to create another div tag
now inside this tip we say
class equal to controls
that's in the Deep tag so under this tip
we want to offer few more buttons
button here we say button ID equal to
start button
start hyphoon BTN
okay and then we say class
class equal to start
hyphen
ptn space between
and we say start here
now just copy this complete line
and put it again so rather than giving
the start button we say
next button and class equal to
next iPhone button
next hyphen button BTN and we'll give
additional property called height
and here we give the value called Next
let me make this S capital
and uh
two buttons we have created
after this Dev tag is getting closed
after that I would like to start another
type
and if this tip tag we will offer
class equal to score
okay
and here
we would like to start working with a
span and here we will say spam ID equal
to
right hyphen
answer
or answers I can see
so after that a deep tag is getting
closed
and that's it and it lasts the last tip
tag is getting closed
which you can see it right now we would
like to use the script tag
but one more thing
this deep tag I would like to close even
before
supportive tags are getting close and
this is another tip type which is closed
at the end and here we want to include
the script tag
the script
SRC equal to
script.js that's it our HTML page is
almost ready Let's review
and
yes I can see some standard buttons has
been created now we would like to look
make gives a better look and feel to
this kind of Button cell complete UI by
offering some awesome CSS
okay everybody so we'd like to start
working with CSS part now
so to work with the CSS we have to offer
few things
here
we're providing a root and we just wrote
some basic settings we are offering it
number one
hyper hyphen Hue hyphen neutral
Q
yphen
hyphen hyphen Q
hyphen neutral the value giving is equal
to 200.
after that we're giving call hyphen
hyphen hue examples again hyphen wrong
this value we're giving is
zero
then we are saying hyphen hyphen here
hyphen
correct
so these three values we have given
followed by body
in this body we would like to offer few
details number one
hyper hyphen hue
this we are making with a variable
how can I open you neutral
the one which we have already declared
okay now we will try to provide adding
so this padding we're giving zero
next property is margin
module also remains zero after that
display
none
after that not display I would say none
instead it is better we can have
Flex
after that width
we are providing with almost 100
followed by height
so height we are providing is called
once again 100
okay now we have called justify contents
this justify contains I can say Center
perfect going forward
align items
here we can say Center again
now background color
which color you would like to give it so
we can just use this option called hsl
in this we will like to use this VAR
again this in this world we are using
iPhone hyphen hue
and followed by 100 percent
comma 20 percent
these things and this is style we're
going to we would like to use in my
index.html page So within my head tag
well in index.html5 how you would like
to define the Styles we always use
link
CSS so the value is automatically
styled.csf but we would like to change
to app
s.css that's it
now let's see the final outcome
now it looks better
okay so it is only for the background
nothing else it is impacting now we want
to offer few more things into my CSS it
is only for the body
now we would like to go ahead with the
body Dot
correct
body dot correct
we are providing
Q
over
and here you would like to offer
iPhone now
and also sorry not wrong just hold
correct
and
we could use
body
dot Raw
body.com
so same thing I'd like to copy
so rather that's incorrect
we're using rocks
well these two properties we have
defined
going forward we would like to start
working with a container
container inside my container I would
like to offer width
basic thing that we are providing 800
pixels
followed by maxword
this Max would be 80 percent
now going forward backer of color
background color we are offering White
that always looks better followed by
border radius
border radius that we are providing 5
pixels
after this padding
this padding will be 10 pixels
followed by box shadow
this box should be considered zero
zero
10 pixels
2 pixels
so this is we have applied for the
container and container is used right
over here let's see
okay now it looks better
so this is where it comes under my
container now we would like to offer the
buttons
here in our CSS
we want to now offer the button colors
so dot
BTN
hyphen
Crypt
well
in index.html file so we have a call
Button grid this button grid we would
like to start from here
between grid between grid display
great
followed by grid
hyphen
template columns
so here we are saying repeat
in this repeat we are saying to
comma
Auto
then we would like to offer the gap
this Gap will be the 10 pixels
followed by margin
that will be the 20 pixels
and then zero
this is for my button grid let's see
awesome so that looks pretty nice
now going forward we would like to apply
the styles on my button
so how my button will looks like in well
button grids we have created it now we
would like to go ahead with the buttons
so dot ptn
followed by the details so
open
were
will be using neutral
what's going forward we would like to
use border
so this border we want to use
12 pixels
or I would say one pixel
and then solid
and hsl
values you would like to give it once
again
War
iPhone I want you
soldered by
100 percent
30 percent
okay so these are the values for Border
followed by background color
so we would like to use the same
details
now we would like to use background
color
so and background color we will just use
hsl rather than this
so high point Hue 100 and 50 percent
okay
followed by border radius
border radius 5 pixels
now padding
padding just 5 pixels
and 10 pixels
then color
this color will be white for sure
and the outline
outline we are using is none
last option cursor
so cursor we will be using pointer as we
should see
so
these are the details are available
which we want to use it
for my button
now the last option
you want to use it for the button hover
Dot vtn
Dot or
and for this pull forward
you want to say border color
this border color you would like to use
black
that's it let's see
awesome
so this looks pretty nice
as you can see right now here
well so
this is how my initial looks like it
okay now I also want to change
this
start button and next button both
so here we want to use Dot
start hyphen BTN
and also for
Dot
next iPhone PT
common look and feel for both font size
one
dot five
next font weight
now this font weight you want to keep
bold
followed by padding
this padding is B with 10 pixels
and 20 pixels followed by 10 pixels 20
pixels
next cursor
will be as usual pointers
now we want to go ahead with the
controls
with Ctrl C display
s
followed by justify contents
justify contain Services Center
followed by align
items
and here we say Center
and last option which is left is called
height
this height is a
display none
that's it let's check this out
well
so
this will be visible to me
so the moment I said start then with
other buttons will be visible so this is
how my program is well my CSS is all set
well let's get start working the script
part now there's a major part of your
main code development so here we will
start working with this const and here
we will say start
button equal to
document Dot
get element by ID and here it will keep
the name call
start iPhone ptn
that's the name like this
I just copy this line
make it available here like we will call
start button
we have a call next button
and here
next button
like here another one
here we change the name and give the
name call question
container element
container
element question container element
documented element by ID
here we give the name called question
hyper container
question iPhone
container because this is already there
you see question hyphen container is
already there
we're using question hyphen container
like this we would like to use one more
and that is called question element
question
element document record element by ID
here will be passing
question
followed by
we want to use
answer button element
answer buttons element
answers
or I can say answer buttons element
answer hyphen buttons
so naming convention must be chosen very
carefully
now we will provide option called
Shuffle question because we want every
time the questions to be get shuffled
shuffled questions
Shuffle questions
current question index
Shuffle questions and current question
index
and we would like to provide one
variable called let
quiz score
zero
so we created those variables
now
once it is done we want to basically go
ahead and start creating a set of
questions for my application
so here we want to provide the questions
so we say const
questions
cost questions
equal to
array first question which I would like
to create it here is called question
now here we will see
foreign
so which of these
is a which one of these I would say
which one of these is a JavaScript
framework
this is my question now
okay so I would like to have answers for
sure
so here we are providing answers
so what answers we would like to provide
so in this answers the first answer I
can say
like this
here I say text
first would be python
python
okay python
answer is true or false
correct
false so it will be the false copy
now let's change the value here I say
Django
correct false
third is react
so
here I can say true
last I'm keeping it score
false as you should see
so like this we have created
a question
and four answers
okay so we're all set now
so here after that we want to create few
more
okay so once again I would like to bring
some questions now
and related answers
so I just copy this
first
foreign
I can say
who is the prime minister of India
so we can have two arms answers
available
okay
talk about converter Modi values called
word true
second you're going to give the name
call
the value is called false
so I've taken the values like this
and we can take one more just for the
demo purpose
so
like here
Mexico what is 4 multiplied by 3.
I can have many answers
so I'm just making the first is called
six
which is false second is true
like that what will be upgraded
three
okay so we all are set with this
multiple questions
okay now once it is done we would like
to offer one function here
okay and what that function would be
the function would be nodes called clear
status class
function
clear
status
it takes some parameter called element
and here we will say element Dot
last list
hello
remove
element dot classlist dot remove
correct
and once again I copy the same line
Raw
[Music]
so we have two options available
right convert Raw
now going forward we want to have few
more functions to be attached there is
only one function we've attached that's
called clear status class
now we would like to add one more
function here
call
function set
status class
okay and here we pass two parameters now
one is called element
and second score correct
two parameters we are passing it down
element and correct first we are calling
this function called clear status class
is a function which we have created pass
element
for the type you're saying if
correct
then
element
Dot
class list Dot
add
correct
okay
else
we use the same option
what we will try to add from here
so this is how we would like to apply
write or wrong
so this is a set status class which we
have it now
solid by the most important function is
you're going to use it right now here is
called
your select answer so you have to
basically select the answer so this is a
little bigger function
so let's try to understand function
select
answer
here we pass e as in parameter
and from here we will use const
select selected button
selected button equal to e Dot
Target
number one second const
correct
equal to
selected button
Dot
data set
select button dot dataset dot
correct
now going forward we'll be calling this
set status class function
in this such status class we'll be
passing
document dot body
as a first parameter
and correct
is the second parameter
okay now we are using
array Dot from
and here in this editor from we are
using answers
button element
Dot
children
okay followed by Dot
for each here
we are using this button
is in parameter
now here what I will do here using this
option called search status class
first parameter will be what
a button then
button Dot
data set
Dot
we can keep the value called what
correct
okay so this is how we are using this
array now we'll be utilizing the main
evaluated value equal if
Shuffle
Dot length
if
Shuffle questions dot length is greater
than
current quotient index
Plus 1.
then what
then we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
and here we will say height so this will
be hidden
okay else
condition says what start button
dot inner text
okay start button dot inner text equal
to
restart
okay and next is called start button
Dot
classlist Dot
remove what we need to remove hide part
that's it
okay and here we're using this option
called if
selected button Dot
data set
equal to
correct
then
quiz score
plus plus
and
document Dot
get element by ID
here we are providing
right iPhone
answers
followed by
Dot
inner HTML equal to
quiz
score
so whatever this code will be after
selecting the correct answer this will
be available to the user
okay now the next thing which we're
going to develop it is basically your
reset state
function reset state
so what we're going to offer here we are
saying
clear status class
document
Dot
dot body
okay here we are saying
next button
Dot
classlist Dot
add
okay now we are using this while option
now
answers put an element
DOT first child
so here I will be using answers button
element
child
here we have a call Dr move child and
here we'll be giving
answers what an element
Dot
first child
so these are the functions are used
right now we haven't called those
functions but we'll be calling those
functions one by one
but this is something which you wanted
to start with
okay
well reset state is already set now
going forward we would like to start
working with the show questions so that
the user can start seeing the question
using function show cushion
show question the first parameter will
be question
and
from here onwards we would like to use
the questionary mode
so we have a call question element Dot
in a text
equal to
question Dot
question
now followed by questions dot answer
question Dot answers
Dot
for each and here I would like to use
we are passing what
answer as a parameter
now here we'd like to create a button
called const
ant equal to
document Dot
get sorry document dot create element
you'd like to create a button now
okay after that we are same
button
dot inner text
you have to set the value equal to
answer
Dot text
Then followed by button Dot
classlist Dot
and here we are
offering
video
okay now you're saying if
the condition is
answer Dot
correct
if answer is correct
then what
then button
Dot
dataset Dot
correct equal to
answer Dot
correct
okay now the next thing is we are using
button
Dot
add event listener attaching The
Listener to this event which event
on click event
second parameter will be
select answer
then
answer whatever element
Dot
app engine of what
button so this is your show questions
followed by what is the next question it
will appear so here we say function
set next question
next question
here
function set next question
here in this next question we are just
saying
reset State the function we are calling
it and saying
show question
and here we are passing this
Shuffle questions
and we are passing this current question
index that is water set next question is
offering it to me now the last function
which is left that is called start game
how the game will start
function
start
game
and here
the main magic begin here we say start
button
dot class list
dot add
and here
height
after that
suffer questions equal to
we have called questions Dot
sort
okay here we say
math Dot
random
and
5. we're passing this value
okay after that we are saying
current question index initially we are
giving 0 right now
after that
question
container element which we have already
defined
Dot
classlist Dot
remove
height
okay and then
calling set next question
which is the function we are calling it
by initializing our quizzes score
with the value calls 0.
well start game is
ready next thing which you have to start
the cover part
so here we are saying
start button
Dot
add event listener
here in this
on my click event
I will try to call this function
start game
first thing now next we'll be calling
next button Dot
add event listener on click
on click
we are using
okay so here we're calling current
question index
current course question index plus plus
and
set next question
that's it
so here are mostly done with our code
script.js We have basically already
initialized there
okay so the values will be kept
automatically
so most of the things are now ready with
us
Okay so
our JavaScript is almost
ready
index.html file is there and app.css is
also ready with us now let's finally see
how my overall look and feel really
looks like it just go here and try to
refresh
and check on a button called start
awesome I could see the first
question appears automatically which of
these a JavaScript framework so if I
select as usual my correct answers for
react now you can see is automatically
making rest of them as a red and not
giving me the next button now
for the prime minister of India and
signature Modi create next and I say
4 multiplied by 3 is at 12 I say next
and which of those used in mobile app
development flutter and flask I say
flask it says Twitter and now you can
see the application looks perfectly fine
and it gives me the restart now
and that's it so this is how dear
friends your project is now completely
working and expected as a way it was
designed for when I once I can restart
and you can say start button not giving
me 4 multiply by three that means it is
one second I have taken random question
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in JavaScript that is known
it's called weatherpro it is in a
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in JavaScript and this is once again a
very competitive project I'm gonna
present you which is called weatherpro
where I would like to offer you the
real-time weather application into your
browser taken from the real-time weather
applications okay so let's get started
with the new development of our
application which is called a
weatherproof now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more a kind of static in nature where
like you talk about snake game you talk
about Tick Tock too or other type of
games like an online quiz where the data
was very much static in nature but we
were presenting the data in the form of
more dynamic in nature this time this
project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where I'll be making a one
rest API call or else you can see
asynchronous call and since JavaScript
is working is about a pure asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the JavaScript can communicate with your
backend load the data and represent the
records in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this vs code
editor only just to develop our code and
once again
for developing a presentation part will
be using HTML for
formatting part will be using CSS and to
make some Dynamic update we'll be using
JavaScript now here I'm going to create
a new file name called index
.html currently I just want one more
that is what is called app.css
and another file we needed and that is
called
your GS file so you're saying
app
Dot js5
so total number of three files are
available to us so I'll start working
with an HTML now and here
will start
with this
HTML templates
now here first of all I would like to
load my CSS file which I do not have
right now but certainly I can use it
okay so I can just say link
Ariel equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot CSS
well that is my CSS location
now I just want to create
some
this link Ariel I would better use
inside my head tag I'll do the more
convenient place
now in my body I want to have some of
the div tags and there I can decide
where the weather to be displayed so I
can just start with my Dev tag now
with my div tag I said
class equal to I could just create a
class which later on I can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say container
so we're saying dip plus equal to
container now within a div tag we'll
like to use another Dev tag which is a
nested one
so this step will have another class
called class equal to
app iphone
title
I have hyphen title in the same div tag
we can use
this a typical paragraph tag and here we
say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag we want to
have a text box because I would expect a
client to enter the detail on which city
or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
some properties like ID
equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
City
next
autocomplete I'm saying autocomplete of
the reason because I do not want the
previous values that can see in this
case we can say autocomplete
off I do not want any autocomplete in
this
okay now here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that I may use some of the PNG files
and all but right now I just want to
display the details of the user like
which city he belongs to in accordingly
I can display the records right in your
application
so for that I really need some of the
div tags once again when I get display
the details
of this particular City so I'm just
having this only text box let me go and
check go back and check
how it looks so I have a call into the
city so here I'll be picking up the city
and somewhere down the line I have to
display
the record so
after this tip
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed so
we can just use the notifications and
also the location where you want the
details to be displayed okay so we can
use div Plus
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so do plus equal to temperature
value inside this I will be using
paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph I'll say hyphen
and this degree Centigrade or whatever
you want to displayed here
and we'll use
spandex in this and show in degrees
Centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description after this Dev
tag we can use another day of tank
and inside my Dev tag I can Define the
temperature description okay so we can
sit here
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description and
within this I will be using what
a paragraph tag
here I'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which I want let me check
okay so it's here right now so now let
me try to collect the value from the
client and perform some JavaScript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the CSS features
insert by code now now few things I
would like to say is I have basically
downloaded some fonts which I would like
to use it in my application and I also
have some of the icons which I would
like to use during my application
presentation so there are some PNG files
available which I've downloaded from the
internet just to bring more beautiful
experience towards my application
development
well this is another background image
which is called vg.jpg which I would
like to make it as a background of my
existing application so I'll start with
my CSS and see how this CSS can really
bring some new features to my code well
first thing I need to have a call
forward face so to make this font face
we are using this statement name call
here at the rate
font face and I like to use Font family
font family amazing
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster it
and the URL
what is looking forward for so we are
saying SRC
URL
and I'm saying under the
font we have a file called tdf
okay that is called
bold.df that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so for every
location I want to use the foreign
family font hyphen
family I want to use same
answer
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
I need URL and in this URL we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that I needed still blue
then I need height
I'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this I needed is Center
next is your background repeat
I say no repeat
next is your background size
this I'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay looks awesome now you see this now
this is how my weather info is looking
like it you can see like the background
looks awesome now now next thing we
require a container
so we are saying Dot
container container we save it
with 50 percent
next background color
which is using white
next we needed to see your align itself
that will be
Center
display
if we block
margin
so in margin you can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius we are saying that pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box Shadow we are giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my content so
index.html file we have a call container
now
okay looks awesome now so this is where
exactly the details will be
okay now
after this thesis
container we have used we can talk about
called title you can say iPhone
title
inside this we will save it
will be 100 percent
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
then we need display
we need Flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying Center
next we need justify content
that will be the Justified content will
be just Center
then Flex Direction
would be column
so this option we are using for our tool
name called what
app iphone title
okay so here in my index.html file we
were called div plus equal to what our
python title we go to weather info let's
check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph so here
this app title
app title is space b but it should be
the class so we are saying Dot
and there also we have to use what
dot because both have to be the Class
Type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference I forgot to add
Dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph So once again in my paragraph
I'll be having text align
sector padding
I want 15 pixels
then I need margin
margin would be zero and
Auto followed by font size
font size these are things called 1.2
here
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value call 333
okay now here
[Music]
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember we have an
index.html file we have a call ID equal
to what
search so here in my app Dot CSS I have
to use hash
search
okay so this search conditions I want to
use it
now inside my search I need few things
one is called display
I need block
after that I need margin left
Auto
marginite
width
I'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
foreign
for 20 pixels
then border radius
I'm looking for for 5 pixels
then outline
that's called none
let me say border
okay in this bottle what we can say
three pixels
space solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you've used display
block
margin
left Auto margin right Auto with 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing I said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40 percent that's why it is
smaller but it will be
forty percent let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready I'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what I need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
know the notifications I would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving White
and after that we are saying display
I'm using none
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all
racing color
color is basically red
okay first if you want to give maroon
and uh after this
the next property we're taking is called
font size
we're taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture line
Center
adding 10 pixels
zero
so this is for notification fee and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container I will say
width
100 percent
sorry yeah width hundred percent height
we're giving 260 pixels
rf2u 250 pixels if you want background
color
this background color we are giving this
call once again White
and followed by margin top
20 pixels
20 pixels this is for weather container
now for the weather icon
weather hyphen
icon I'm saying width
is 100 percent
and height
128 pixels
Crystal cube in a better look
now the next thing we're using Dot
weather
hyphen icon space IMG
here we going display
none
and
sorry display not none I will say rather
block
display block and margin
giving zero
Auto
foreign
location icon if I want to give then
location hyphen
icon
this location icon I can save it same
width height
so
width I'm giving is 100 percent
then
height I'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option call
adding
then take access
first location icon
now followed by location icon we are
also giving call location icon IMG okay
dot
location hyphen icon space IMG
here we're getting the value called
display block
on display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward margin
margin would be 10 pixels
all right
order
then cursor
so cursor will be pointer for sure
and then we required padding
padding me looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
Loop
steel blue
solid
and two pixels
that border radius
quarter
radius we're looking forward for 10
pixels
and followed by your color
so these are the look and feel
beautiful
current application which I here to
discuss in my next development
then I'll be having some small small
properties here
okay and those properties are nothing
but to give you the details of
like temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyper value we can
give it
is 100 percent
and height
we can just call 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again and I'm giving this
temperature value space paragraph
here I'm gonna give padding
zero
margin
then color
which color you're looking forward for
we can just say dark gray
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to the another one we're giving this
call Hash 293
okay two five one
okay that is a more perfect color for
this development now font size
4 em
Then followed by texture line
and once again Center
so this is for temperature value p
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value P
then you can use the temperature values
Prime
here Dot
temperature value span
space
span and here
we remove the additional dot now within
this is spam
say color
once again same
and font size
[Music]
this is for
span and in the same temperature
description paragraph you can use it
Dot
temperature iPhone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
the margin
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
after this color just select texture
line
sector font size
1.2 EU
this is for temperature description
okay plus which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now Dot
space p here we can say margin
zero
then padding
then color
same color I would like to use
after this color text align
and font size
and copy
text align Center and here will be
giving some different value called 0.8
okay and last which is left with equal
to
invert
relative here position
I'll be using
absolute
talk from Top
I'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
I'm using 120 pixels
that's it okay so all set
[Music]
so you can see now here we have to
basically offer the details how my
pictures will be taken it out so this is
what my CSS now we'll be applying some
of the CSS into my applying the CSS into
my HTML to see how it really looks like
it if getting your learning started is
half the battle what if you could do
that for free visit scale up by simply
learn click on the link in the
description to know more
okay so we have seen some of the CSS
classes we have introduced in my HTML
we have used this
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used strip classical root temperature
value okay if you just check carefully
we have used this temperature and if we
have used temperature hyphen value but
before that we would like to use some
other properties too
okay after this auto complete equal to
off we want to use
another Dev class okay before my
previous depth I guess closed here so
here
after this people like to use another
Dev tag
do
here in my tip
I'll say plus equal to location hyphen
icon
location hyphen
okay and here I'll be using IMG
SRC
equal to what under
icons I'm using the file name called
location
dot PNG
and ALT equal to we leave it as it is a
blank
okay now here the Dev tag is getting
closed
okay now there's another Dev tag is
getting closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another depth class for
notification here real
class equal to notification
div class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another tip for the weather
condition
another tip type and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what a condition
or I can say whether iPhone container
whichever so I can say
weather hyphen container under this
weather container I like to use
another tip for weather icon
tip 4
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
I want to use another IMG
SRC equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot PNG
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed I'm
gonna use
temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see resin call temperature
value after the first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used after that the paragraph tag and
the temperature hyphen description V
after the P that the div tag is getting
close
okay and after this we are using tip
class equal to location
so we want to use
do
plus equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
with this hyphen
after this paragraph it's close just
step tag this step tag
another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it and at the last
before my body tag is closed I would
like to use
SRC equal to
oh
dot juice
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now so this I want to be
displayed only when I don't find the
weather and the location anymore so look
and feel is absolutely good and now I'll
start working on my JavaScript
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our JavaScript code so in this
JavaScript code first of all I need few
things
uh first thing what I need is called
individual elements or individual
properties of my application I need cost
icon element
I can limit equal to
document Dot
query selector
and I'll be using the name call
Dot
Twitter hyphen
icon
okay now
copy this
foreign
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen
icon
now
next I need it is called temp element
here using
the property called Dot
temperature hyphen
value space p
next we're looking forward for
DEC element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyper
description
hyphen
temperature having description space
Squad
P then location element
okay we need location element when we
use dot location
foreign
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
gonna give the call notification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this is stating it is all about
selecting the arguments the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying VAR
input
equal to
document Dot
get element by ID here we give the name
call
search which is the name or ID of my
text box select
City equal to blank
next we're gonna Cube score let latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input Fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable Dot
add event listener the variable what
we're talking about which event list
will be talking about key up
okay
up and what even you want to apply so we
are saying
function with a parameter name called
what
event and now we would like to attach
the logic now you think if
what are the condition
event Dot
key code
equal to
30.
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means what 13 13
represent the enter keywords so
event.key code equal to what 13 so here
same event
dot prevent default why we're using this
because I do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we are
using this and after that we are saying
City
equal to
input Dot
[Music]
value
now you'll be using this or other
function because I do not have function
created otherwise I have to call the
function name called get search whether
I will be passing this as in parameter
so we are going to get
search
whether I do not have this function I
yet to create this and pass it here as a
what
City and you say console DOT log
City whatever we are basically printing
it
okay so that's the first thing later on
we need to get the data so to get the
data we are just using this variable
name called const
whether
equal to const whether equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather Dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want I'm saying unit
of type what Celsius
I want in a Celsius
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin I'm saying
const Kelvin
equal to value of the Kelvin is about
and after that
corn C ultimately what we need is we
need to interact with our backend API
from where I will get or receive the
updated weather applications
okay now
to get this I'll be using one very
popular API here that is known as call
open weather map.org
this is all very very popular app which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear so here what you can do this open
with the map.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular unique API
key
since as a visitor you really can't get
it unless you register yourself so I
have
my API key with me so I'll go here
It'll ask me for the registration
so I already signed up so if you're not
easy to sign it there's an API key for
me which I need to copy and this API key
I'll be using it in my project
so I'll just use this property called
const
k equal to
paste my key here
okay after this paste in the key but
make sure that you rather using my key
you use your key otherwise this
application sometimes won't work
so I'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation I'm saying if
jio location
okay and
Navigator
Navigator is you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we are using
Navigator
okay Navigator Dot
jio location
Dot
get current position in which I'll be
passing the first parameter new convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
the error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
I'm using this statement in call
notification
element
this is notification element Dot
Style Dot
notification remain Dot
get Elements by class name
but I don't need this rather I will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then I'll be using the same
notification element Dot
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of use
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location will be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will I'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position Dot
Chords chords for coordinates Dot
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position Dot
chords
Dot
longitude
after this we'll be using this function
called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon same I'll
be having it defined below but as of now
we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this functioning called what
set
position in which we'll be passing all
the values
okay at the same time
I'll be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
I would like to use location
icon the one which you've defined as a
top part
argument listener which even listeners
answering one click
second
function which take
event is in parameter
and inside this I'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey just and
we say get with it
okay once again we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same I just copy
this
paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when I try to run my browser so I
should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined but
obvious because this message what we're
writing it here is called show error
okay this as a function as a parameter
it is not defined let me Define this
function called show error so we are
saying
function
show error which take
errorism sorry just take
errorism parameter
in this we are using
notification
Dot
Style
dot display equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element Dot
inner HTML
equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error Dot
foreign
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if I say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment I click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because I told you
this get whether function I need to
develop so I get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that I'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search whether in which I will be
passing what
city name now what exactly my API will
be in case if I want to make a call I
will be using let
API equal to now so URL will be what
HTTP colon double forward slash API Dot
open
the weather map Dot org now open weather
map.org
slash data
slash two point
sorry 2.5 that is a version slash
whether
okay question mark
I have to take the city dynamically so
I'm saying whether
question mark Cube
equal to
here
we're using what city
and we're using and percent
app ID equal to double app ID we have
used it already
okay what is that that key
so that is the key
which you've already written that app
ideally we are passing it right over
here
okay Q equal to city and iPad equal to
this
now after that to make the restful API
call I'll be using one independent or
by default EPA which is available to us
that is one is called what fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take request info and
give you the word a promise response so
return type will be the promise type in
this fetch I will be passing what the
API
and will be using dot then that means if
the request
is successful using function
response
then function is a parameter response we
are saying let
data equal to
response dot I'm expecting the response
of stripe of what Json is in Json now
and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now if it is successful then what then
I'll send dot then once again it is
chaining again function again
datas and parameters now in this case
we'll be getting lot of things I am
saying
whether
okay dot temperature it's predefined Dot
value equal to I'm using what
math Dot
flow inside this we are causing what
data Dot main dot temp it is a
predefined property we are receiving it
now hyphen
Kelvin what are the Kelvin values
basically we're taking Square 273 on the
top
minus Kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather Dot
description
whether dot description
equal to we're using data Dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains lot
of data but I will be taking what
description out of that then
weather Dot
icon ID
whether or not I can ID equal to
data
Dot
weather
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather Dot
City
okay equal to
data Dot
name
after this
weather.country
Dot
equal to data dot sys Dot
so these are the properties I have it
right now with me
okay and once I received all the
property I'll be using Dot
then
I'll be using one function
and I will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but I'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display together
this function I had to write but this
function just putting it here
okay now this is closed after that
since I need to get a weather from the
APA provider so I have to also pass what
the latitude and longitude which I am
receiving it from the client because
here I just want to have two things the
properties as well as whether both and
both I'll be using it one by one okay so
here we have kept this get search
weather and now I'll be calling one more
function after this logic and I'm giving
the name call function
get with it
it takes two parameter one is called
what latitude
and second is called
longitude so we have two things called
attitude and longitude and here I'm
using this property called what lit
API equal to once again if you remember
uh I've used this statement I'll just
copy the same
and password it here
but challenge would be this time
I will not be passing city name because
their two options are available either
you type the city name or else you click
on the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this weather question mark
here I will not be using Q I'm using
what led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using and
Halloween
equal to
we're using longitude
okay and applied equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay now similar thing which we have
used it on the top
okay called Fetch API so I just copy
this same fetch API again
because I really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code when we
know it very well it can be similarly
done I just copy here
paste it here so the same fetch API dot
then response data equal to response dot
Json return data then whether the
temperature matte or flow says country
dot display weather so we have used the
same thing here and after that we have
to use the last function here that is
called display weather
display weather and here in my display
weather I can use
what icon element Dot
inner HTML equal to
I'll be using
IMG
SRC
equal to
icons
slash dollar
and we'll be passing what weather
okay dot
icon ID
PNG
Okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot PNG and after that
we're just closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
rather than closing this I'll be closing
that and this I'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry Temple event
thumb element
Dot
inner HTML equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
whether Dot
temperature Dot
value
okay and after this value we can just
use
this asterisk sign
the one which I told you
okay and use
this one
okay next we are using call torque
element
so we have create sorry DAC limit
for DEC element Dot
inner HTML equal to
weather Dot
description
and last but not least location
element Dot
in your HTML equal to
what
I'll be using one second this
and here
weather Dot
City
comma
dollar
weather Dot
that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we are all done let's check with my
code if I get any error
no allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds Globe undefined that's
perfectly fine Intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's like
smoke 28 degree centigrade and on let me
put another city here I'm gonna say
chord Pune
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
I would say
awesome and now we are planning to
develop our very special game for you
in JavaScript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known called Tic Tac
tic-tac-toe is world's favorite game we
have already played a lot in our
Childhood Days and still my favorite
game so I have decided to basically
offer you this tic-tac-toe game
developed in JavaScript HTML plus CSS
which can create something really really
great effects for the end users so let's
go and start developing our next game
that's called tic-tac-toe so in this Tic
Tac Toe I will start working with
creating a folder called Tic Tac and
inside this I'm going to create a new
file name called index
dot HTML
now here are words the same thing
I'll be creating this HTML tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer but so we're going to create some
depth diagram
so in this div tag
I'll be creating some of the tags
in which the CSS class will be applied
so we just gonna create a classes
for languages use those classes but
we'll create it later on so just go
ahead and create the soothing div
okay so now this point onwards is my
first Dev tag inside this I'll keep
my H1 tag
and under this H1 I will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tip here we
say H1
and insert this H1 we give the message
called class
equal to header
and here I'll give the name code
is a Tic Tac token
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag I will start my div
after div tag I will use label
so label for player one
or else I can say player one and inside
this let's give the name call
player one label is closed and after
this label will start working with our
input tag
input
now in this input what are the details I
need first I need called type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to layer 1
next we want ID equal to
layer 1 and then
any class if I want to play
anyways we're going to close this this
is my first text box and same thing I
would like to create for my another one
so the first step tag we have used let
me go and create another tip tag
in this div tag I'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this two players with me and
after this div tag and offer the submit
button now
submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
Dev tag is also closed
so you want a div tag to be closer
before that it's up to you now so here
we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we have a basically form that with us
so form tag is there later on you can
just show some containers where the
details will be visible to me so here
after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check
whether it's really working fine
so here
yep we have this option called enter
name internet so
yeah so here the details we have taken
input available text and then put up a
little text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the trip tag again
div and insert this div
since I haven't created any CSS classes
so those we can use it little later on
but let's have this tip
and insert this div I would like to use
remote depth type
foreign
so in this div we can just give the
value called Data ID equal to zero
ID equal to
zero it's just a value we are passing it
div data is equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so that's how we want it now so
here the first step tag is closed like
that we can create another data ID so 0
1 2 total number of three we want to
create it so I want to create 0 1 2 3 4
5 like this so the way we have created
here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
ID equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that I can keep on creating
the others also
true
three
four
five so zero one two three four five
part number of five we operated
one more I would like to create it down
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay so the div tag is getting closed
here
okay and uh
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
border button that you can basically
offer it a little later on
but here
we can use one more dim
and here we say Dev
class equal to relating
and within this type I can use any image
type if I want
so I just leave it as it is and after
this I can create one more tip type
and inside is another tip
okay and under this I'm going to create
a button
okay and in this button will be having
some value
okay we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
is just
a small game I want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure look at field so that you know it
gives me more better look when your
application will start
but most importantly I need to start
working with a JavaScript part where the
logic will get calculated here
Okay so
we want to start with the JavaScript so
let's get included the JavaScript with
my code so here
I can see here a script tag
script
equal to
now the file I haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my style sheet
also so I just say
link audio equal start sheet
and get the name called app Dot
see says go ahead and create it but I'm
giving it
okay
that's it
so we have taken this HTML into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
CSS as well as the JavaScript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our HTML but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our JavaScript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js and inside this we will start
writing the logic with our main
application okay now the first thing is
are we going to start now yeah so first
thing what we need to do is we need to
attach window
Dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so I'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but I can give the name call
app which I'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game mode I'm saying lit
game board
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making it right
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create lit
turn
this new variable equal to zero what
this is it keep tracking if x or zero
player it's done
like which player turns it will be
suggest it is trying to measure it so
I'm saying let
winner equal to
pause
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
player how are you going to create a
player if you say const
left equal to what you gonna pass name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
that's it
okay after that I'm defining lit
here
x equal to
clear
with the empty value
and again
clear why
equal to layer is an empty value now
let's try to initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initialize the app we're
going to create a new function
function app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying let
input feed
foreign
document dot get element by ID here
we're gonna take
the class name of this particular text
field so we are saying input
iPhone
field
okay
Dot
Focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add please
equal to once again
document Dot
get element by ID where we just give the
new code player form
okay next we are saying add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add Blues
okay after that on the players are added
we are saying let replay
button equal to once again
document sorry yeah dot get element by
ID or rather I will say document.query
selector
document dot query selector
replay it
here
okay it will adjust the name we are
basically taking that and here we say
sorry
replay button Dot
add event listener which even I want to
say
click
okay that is the first event second
reset hold
reset
you are basically pass into it
okay now
this is the initial case which we have
it now beyond that I will add this is
the place what we have added right now
it slides to add the players so this is
how we've initialized after that let's
add
plates
how to basically add the players here we
have to just Define the function
add
please okay so take
event as a parameter and say event
Dot
prevent
default this prevent report will try to
prevent the default
you know Behavior which is submitting to
make it avoided and now here we say if
this Dot
clear
1 which is defined for property called
player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is blank
okay or
just start
play to
this Dot
player two
now I just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what I should do in this case I am
saying alert
U
must
enter name
for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
editor
okay now the next thing is like we would
like to select the plates in this inside
this by saying first
layer
form
foreign
query selector
documentary query selector here we will
just pass
the value column
enter icon
yes
okay now we say const
ant
equal to
document dot once again
query selector
code underscore I mean
okay after that
player form container Dot
class list
dot class list dot add here we're giving
the name for what height and Taylor
all right
and after that you just say board mail
board main dot class list
Dot
remove
find hyphen container
okay so we have basically taken that and
after this what I will do I'll just say
player
x dot name equal to this Dot
player one
Dot
value
okay this is for player x copy this
clearly
two and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which
we've implemented
well so add player function is added
right now and after this add player we
have to basically call one more that is
called which Returns the current player
so I'm saying return
current player
and here what I will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
test variable
okay percentile
we're just adding it with this
zero
okay if it is
then X turn I'm telling you
okay or else
so we are in like the current player who
says the current player right now
well after this adding the return
current player we're gonna add another
function that is known is called return
the current flame written current player
is having this value and after that we
need to say resize the square in event
browser is resized once again if the
browser is getting resized automatically
the square size of your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
precise
squares
and here we're gonna save this option
equal window
Dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here and the second parameter what
you're passing is called
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function on
resize that is the functioning for me
the one which you're passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let all cells
equal to
document
Dot
query selector all
foreign
board
underscore
okay and then we're using another option
called what lit
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set width
or
after that we are saying all cells
Dot
for each here we are passing cell
and after that we are using cell
Dot
style Dot
height
equal to now I will be using this
backtick and the uses
dollar sign and say
cell
height
and that too in a pixel so this will be
taking the dynamic values
okay that's it that's it over now we
have to just launch our build board
now
billboard
build
so how are we gonna build our board now
for this we are saying function
build port
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document Dot
once again query selected and pass the
value called dot reset
okay and after that we are saying reset
container Dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset iPhone
hidden this value and after that we may
call some other type of functions also
okay so for those functions I can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling add cell click
listener
but I do not have that function with me
but these functions we need to create it
by our own
okay so we will just link those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self-click
event for play to attempt to make move
so here we try to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to make this
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function and give the name
of the function
to make move Now function make
move it takes
if it doesn't parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say done
now let's go back and try to check the
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what event Dot
current Target
sorry
given Dot current Target Dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot ID
so we're reading these values after that
we use another variable called it
set to
add
token now here we are typing document
dot query selected
and here
you know using backpick I'm using this
value called
data hyphen ID
okay equal to
here we are using once again in a single
quotes
dollar
current cell
okay so this value we are taking it like
that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell to add token Dot
inner HTML
explanatory mark
blank
once again if Cell to add
token dot inert HTML
equal to blank then what next
so sell to add token dot inner HTML
equal to like that what you should do
I'm saying console
DOT log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay so in this console.log what value
we can give it
sell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current cell dot inner HTML
console.log and inside my console.log we
can set this
cell is
quantity take care
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
is X
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to add tokens so
we're saying cell to add token okay dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and we say game board
the one which you've created pass in
this game mode
this value called
current cell and in this correct cell
value will be equal to
X
okay else
we can see
to add token Dot
text content equal to
current player
okay and Save
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name code is winner to
check whether the user is winner or not
so we are saying is
winner
okay and after that we are saying
turn
let's press
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being and we'll call
this little later on so
leave it as a full time being
okay so your function is now ready so
the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
three
we're just taking the function
whether this game is Thai or not so here
we say if
the condition is turned
greater than 7
alert
again
okay we can say give over as we can see
our time
okay well after that we are saying
winner
function
now what we will check is you will check
once
willing sequences
winning sequences and here
sorry here we are having this array and
having the different conditions
Associated we say zero
one two probability we are checking it
and then I just copy it
well we are saying 0 1 2 and here we say
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call 258
then we are checking the vertical zero
four eight
it and one more last option we will put
is equal to four six
so these conditions we are adding it now
after this array we can say
winning sequences start
for each
and equal winning compost
wedding
compost
and inside this winning compost we are
giving lid
cell 1 equal to
varying Commerce position 0
then
copy
and paste three times
cell to
cell 3
and here we get together called what one
two three words are giving it and after
that
we are checking the condition
let's say
if
any other conditions you're checking
what exactly that will be for the game
board you're saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
Ampersand time percent
come down
to game board
I just want to copy this the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
and after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position called
[Music]
recording this condition call
cells const
since and then equal to
document Dot get element by or sorry
document or query selector
query selector all and here let's select
the position Dot
board
underscore
okay then after that we will be using
cells
Dot
for each
cell
an inside is what you're processing we
are saying let
cell ID equal to
cell Dot
first
element child
okay dot
data set
dot ID so this is the value which you
are basically adding it now and we're
using one more different condition
pressing if
cell ID
now we're talking about wholesale ID
triple equal to
cell one
or
salary
salary equal to
cell 3 okay and in that case we can use
cell Dot
class list
Dot add
get the name for board
just give the class name
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is adding the value and
now let's say
let
current player equal to
document Dot
get element by ID
so you can basically Define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current player or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now Small Change rather than using
current player we can use
the current
player text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot
brothers and same get element by ID
you can see query selected
and in this query selector you'll be
giving the value by saying dot board
foreign
in that query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it here
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked okay
current player
X
then what
then in this case we can say
current player whatever the value we are
using current text Dot
inner HTML
equal to now we can Define the value
whichever you want to operate
we just use a condition called div
plus equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
all right
okay and here you see
congratulations along with
this dollar sign
and here we pass
player file Dot
name
right here the div tag is getting closed
like this
okay so that's the message we are
basically printing it and after that we
give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return true only
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if winner
all right yep
winner
or you can see
check if I
am
written Force
that's it
now in a contribution to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
change
board header names
Change Port header names will be the new
function for us and here we would like
to check whether the user is winner or
not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to select
current layer text equal to
document Dot
query selector in this we'll be getting
the details like Dot
or
and here we're gonna give the name
called player
and hyphen turn
player hyphenator
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current layer
equal to X if the position is X sorry
let me try to put in a capital letter
here
X
then we have to say
current player Dot
inner HTML equal to now here we have to
just use the same option called back
text because I want to go multi lines
that's the benefit of this package and
here we say in our inner HTML span
class equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
Style
close this and here we want to use
the statement now this
value we want to write it with name
attribute so it is getting close and
here we are saying dollar
with this player
x dot
name
and then
closer
span tag
and we say
you are
okay
like this and after that
we say div
class equal to which is going to create
a class which later on we can apply the
CSS Style on the top of that U hyphen R
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the diff type
so deep tag is closed that's it and now
after this line
but next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current player
text
dot inner HTML
inner HTML equal to
after this
we're going to write the spam
class equal to here we say email
hyphen hyphen same option we're going to
use it so in this condition so winner
conditions so let me try to copy the C
rather than copying it again and again
I'll just copy the whole text
span class equal to name hyphen hyphen
style player rather than saying X you
have to use y you are up you are
better
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we have to do
create another function called reset
code
function
reset both
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message
by resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using the game board and the
same game board what we have used it
earlier
I'll be using the same conditions
on the top if you remember that was the
game code for me so I'll be using the
same game board
recopy this
here
with the same condition
okay gameplay could do this after that
line it will say let
cell to add token
sell to add token equal to
document dot query selector all
here
in this I'll be using another class
called
now
sell to add token
whichever we've used Dot
for each
Square
and within this Square we would like to
use Square
Dot
text content equal to Black
after that
Square
Dot
parent element Dot
class list Dot
remove
and here we would like to say both
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we have to
create because these changes classes we
are just using this but we haven't
created we'll be using it little later
on
so that was the point
now after that we are defined the term
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that winner is equal to false we
just Define another variable called
Define let current player text
current layer text equal to
document
Dot
query selector all
yeah document query selector all so here
we're gonna use the name call board
Define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current player
text
currently text Dot
inner HTML equal to once again you have
to use the condition for up
and winner point so let me try to copy
this
inner HTML equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot need
okay just everything is same
no digital
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when I will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell what
kind of event I would like to listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
Dot
query selected all
let's check
the condition board
[Music]
cell and here once again we say cell
stop for each
Dot
for each
and here this is cell Dot
add event listener which event I want to
listen
click and the second parameter will be
Handler
on score
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add self clicks listener
okay this I'll be calling it here
perfect later on once it is done let's
try to add one more function called
function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell click listener
now here we say let
all
cells equal to
document Dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell and now we say
all cells Dot
for each
cell
and here we say cell Dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here most of
our JavaScript code is written now so
going forward we would like to use CSS
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our HTML file
well after the Javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create our HTML file now sorry
the CSS so inside my Tic Tac I have got
app.js and index.html ready now here I'm
going to create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.cs in either folder like in static
folder but I have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards I would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called morning
with my body
some basic settings I would like to do
like in background image background
color so I just start with
background color
background color I can just use it as a
white
okay but I don't think it's really
needed it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background probably
because it's by default going to be
white only
and now next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position I just say like
Center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here I say no repeat
next background size
here using cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part now
the next thing is we have to select the
rest of the CSS classes first select div
IDE dot relative
inside this data dot relative is first
record position
we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top I'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right here just say 120 pixels
next after this we are saying hide
container
height Dot container or sorry height
hyphen container
here in hide hyphen container we will
display
colon none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header
inside the seller we will say color will
be by default white but still we just
say color
and
White
next text line
we just say Center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family I'm selecting call permanent
marker
permanent
okay
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that is called Dot
enter
hyphen
players
I need to have a place with the same
color
will once again
we can use any other layer but we can
just use white or any color you want or
you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we're giving it's called zero
Auto width
we're looking forward for 80 percent
next text align
Center
position
now next we are going forward for input
field
in this input field we just say border
border 2 pixels
solid
and black
next outline
outline none I do not want any outline
to be there
next padding
I can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels 8 pixels now margin
we're saying zero
zero 10 pixels
okay and finally 4 pixels
after switching we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field Focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
Focus
now here
border
2 pixel
solid
all right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want to submit button to be so
I'm saying Dot
submit hyphen BTN
border
two pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
18 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
five mixes
next your margin from Top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
foreign
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate with
your submit button active and submit
button Focus so we are saying Dot
submit hyphen vtn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline now
outline
and then next border
we're talking about Core 2 pixels
solid
and the color
right
okay
so that's the one
and after that we'd like to use over dot
submit hyphen button colon
over
what you want
change the background color to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we'd like to use uh
Dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
these are the classes we were using in
our JavaScript we remember
and here we say color
gonna be using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on text align
Center margin
10 pixels
zero
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here I'm saying Dot name hyphen hyphen
style and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about the
next important call border container
called board container plot
bot container here we Define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 we cannot take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay next margin
we're taking is zero
okay
Auto
after that font size
font size we are taking zero
next border
border we are taking two pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
if you remember this box shade is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we are
defining three pixels
3 pixels
zero pixels
and RGB we can talk about called Black
okay so my border color will be shading
color will be black
after that we're offering this board
cell
Dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
foreign
now in this width we are using
calculation
CA LC and in this calculation we are
defining 100 percent
okay divided by 3.
this calculation after this the next
property will be displayed
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well text align
set border
we are taking 2 pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
can use permanent
permanent markers
okay now
next option
a part of this we have a call your board
signal
board
cell hyphen
winner
I would say rather
no it's starting wrong this is
here Port cellular let's make background
color
okay and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
White
next position
relative top
50 percent
next transform
translate by
2 minus 50 percent
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay now here next option will be called
winner container here we're giving
winner
with DOT
Dot winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container what
are the values we want to use it that's
you want to basically do it so if all
this winner container what I would
rather suggest is you can use Dot
reset
extra line
Center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset again we will set
display now
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah I'm going to talk about replay
button Dot
replay hyphen
video and here with
we make it through
25 percent
okay and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here and 20
pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called two
pixels
followed by solid
okay and black color
now later on border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
and signal
after this outline we say little spacing
now this little spacing would be again
zero
after that
text transform
this text log form where we are talking
about call
uppercase next font size
font size we are taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top will be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you're taking three pixels
followed by background color
is your ticking white as usual
so this is for your replay button
okay now in a similar line we can also
have
call Dot
replay hyphen BTN
colon over
followed by Dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
that color
we are making it is called White
then background color
will be black
okay and when it comes to the
congratulations
so we'll be using this Dot
okay so this congratulations class will
be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this called
winner dot U
hyphen r dot winner
in this winner we'll be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and then
margin 2 pixels
and then 0.
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this Dot
replay
hyphen BTN
this I'm saying with 50 percent
so this is what my C6 file is all set
I know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our CSS also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file and take care about
the final finishing touch so we have
this index.html file with us and now the
CSS class which we were using it in our
application that is known as call this
uh
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this using this external API so here
where we have a call CSS with us before
that
we want
link
So within this link we want our variable
name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot Google apis
okay.com
slash CSS
question mark
family equal to
permanent
Plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser you will get to know
where exactly it is using okay if I just
copy and paste it
so I just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts Dot
Google apis .com
slash or spelling wrong
CSS family equal to permanent marker
that is the main URL from where I can
take this kind of font so here
CSS so that's what I was cross verifying
it well it's there we have included our
CSS also but in which class we need to
use that is an important now
yes I also want to include it
so here in my head type only I would
like to include
script
SRC equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if I just go back and check
the final outcome of my code
which is index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about called start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no CSS class are attached so I need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those CSS classes so that at
least I can apply those common behaviors
to my application
okay like here we have a call
div we haven't attached any class to
this
after this body we have a part tip H1
class equal to header Tic Tac Toe then
we have a code div we have a call
body
under this we have a call another Dev
tag so just imagine how many type of
classes are available one we have called
tip class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a call
for more div tag so like that multiple
CSS files are there where we have to
apply the new CSS class to make it
happen so now we have to just go back
and change our HTML and to apply our
main class
so this is what my final HTML which
looks like the same you can see we have
added all those type of csys classes
which we had that is called interpreter
platform player container level
placeholder and player container and if
you see all different type of classes we
have attached this to
okay because
here only my CSS class will get applied
and the JavaScript will apply those kind
of dynamic CSS based on certain
conditions so these CSS classes are
already there added inside your HTML
page our app CSS is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like it
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
which is start game it says You must
enter a name for each field validation
is working let me try to add
two names and says start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying a you are
up now let me try to give the values
foreign
like hey you are a winner great so guys
congratulations on this the first
example of how the tic tac toe game is
used so it is a classical example of CSS
JavaScript and HTML together so this
time we're going to talk about our next
very interesting feature that is known
is called dealing with another example
that is called snake game so snake is
one of the very very powerful example
which I'm going to share with you which
will help you to understand like how we
offer a very simplest way of developing
a mini project okay that is something
which is a snake game let's see how the
snake game is important and how we're
gonna deal with this these are our
previous examples which we have seen
whichever call a project which we have
created that is called quiz application
and now we're going to start working
with our new project now here first of
all I'm going to create a new folder
that is called snake
again
an inside is a snake game we need some
new folders uh first folder I'm going to
create it inside this that is called
images
and within this snake games I'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
.html
and here
I'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot JS at the same time I'll be having
some of the CSS files if I need so I can
say app Dot CSS so total number of three
files I have it now let me close down
all the files whichever I have opened it
earlier
so now that looks cleaner approach so
this is a snake game for us from where
we need to start and we have a
index.html file and here I will as you
create
our basic HTML syntax and here I would
like to include
our script tag
script
SRC equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing our next implementation
of sneaky
now inside my body tag I would like to
have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on I'll be taking the
input from the client so we're saying
input type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give ID equal to
game speed
and followed by value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value and Min equal to
1 that is the minimum value and Max
equal to 9 that is the maximum and
minimum value we can offer beyond that I
won't allow the users to go and step
that means the increment value that is
1.
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button and value
equal to
start
and then ID equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
I can give some
bricks
so two bricks we're giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this step tag I'll be using the
canvas
this is a HTML5 feature
we use canvas and I just give ID equal
to
game
area
there's a canvas and after this canvas
we will
that div tag is closed here after div
tag I can use another Dev tag
div here I can say plus equal to
[Music]
I may not have any class return but I
can say
class equal to relative so later on if I
want to apply any CSS style I can
certainly apply
and after that I can offer the images
okay so I may not have any images right
now so I just leave this image blank
right now
okay and this is script SRC I'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so I can see values
and minimum is one start with the button
which is not doing anything but later on
we can allow some logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main JavaScript tag this is my app.js
and here onwards we will use
some of the properties okay which I want
to initialize it so we are saying or
start
equal to none
initialized second game speed
equal to
none
next game area
equal to
null
Game Area context
equal to null
then give area width
Game Area width
equal to
0 that is in integer value Game Area
height
game area
equal to 0 again
then solve it
solve it equal to zero
play score
equal to 0 again
next snake
equal to null
next is snake food
next snake Direction
equal to null
snake speed or else I can say speed size
speed size
equal to 0
next we have our timer
equal to
so these number of properties we've
initialized
okay now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
and it was called initialize
okay and you're in the initialized we
would like to use some of the properties
first we are saying game start equal to
document Dot
and get element by ID here I can give
the value called hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
okay
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed these all values we
have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me see the another one
that is called game speed
game speed equal to again
document Dot get delivered by ID now we
are passing the game speed okay
game speed
now
here
once again I will take another point
game area
I say game
area here you have to give the value
called game area
okay so these values we have taken now
we'll be talking about called game video
context
view mirror context equal to
game area
Dot
get context
get
and in this game context we'll be using
what type of context we are seeing 2D
okay because I want to have the kind of
2D so this is how the kind of
environment we want to set next we talk
about Game Area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
Game Area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so Game Area Dot
width equal to
Game Area width
and then we Define K media dot height
Dot
equal to
the game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this okay now after that we
have to start writing the logic here I'm
saying game start
game start dot now we have to line which
event you would like to take so I will
say on
click
on click
so when I basically click what should
happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here I'm
saying this Dot
this dot disabled
equal to true
so I want to disable these values and
after that we want to call another
function inside this but which function
let's do that so here we are saying
function
start game start
okay and here in start game we want to
Define the initial score see the initial
score for the player will be certainly
zero so we say
player
score equal to zero
after that direction in which direction
you want the snake to move so we are
saying snake
Direction equal to right
in the right direction then speed size
the value of sorry the variable which
you defined so speed size equal to
because it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it turns certainly will be
string type so we have to use power set
so using this option called percent and
here we are using
game speed dot
value
okay so we are using this value again
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things
what those are first we are saying if
okay what if condition
uh see this function we are writing
called start game
because there are certain things which
you need to make it so like that we have
to Define it so function initialize
we have started okay and then after that
we have written on clicking within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started start game
and now we'll be writing the logic for
this so here we are saying if these
things print size
missing if speed size
greater than 9.
in case if it is the value is hard coded
it then we would like to write a logic
here
and what this logic would be if says if
it is greater than 9 we say speed size
equal to 9.
we basically initialize to what the name
here we say else if
size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size equal to 1 that means if it
is less than 0 I will be making it
minimum to one if it is greater than 9
I'll be making it to 9 maximum and
that's it
okay so after this lcf condition
is getting closed we are saying speed
size equal to 1 so here we just say
snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards by saying X
position 0 and
then the Y
and here the Y value will be what
solve it that means how far it can go so
will it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call salvate
which we have given here after that what
we have to do is
we have to Define our own function
called
clear interval and this clear interval
perform any logic whichever I would like
to make it
okay so here after the snake.push value
has been given
here I will be creating one more
function here that's known as call
create food okay so here we're saying
create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this one should be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are saying the
function called clear interval
clear interval with a timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that this clear interval will
be same timer
equal to
set interval
with this we're saying create game area
create
now here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically Implement so here we are
giving this called create food is a
function we are calling after that we
are calling this clear interval clear
interval will be just like in a typical
function which is there after that we
are using this option called create game
area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you how
you can call this function create food
and how to create it first well so we
are talking about a functionality call
create game interval so this create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the same set
interval this function is not right
there so we have to basically go back
and create this function within my
application
right so what we will do is just
particular one we will try to comment it
for a time being okay so here we have a
call what create interval in this
gradient level will be
passing any parameters which we have
password about as a timer here and here
we are calling this called create food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
then this function create food let's go
and write the logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
foreign
and here in our curly basis we use two
Direction X and Y
we say in X we say
math Dot
round
and insert this we say
math
Dot
random
after this method random function we
have to just take this calculation and
check the another parameter called Game
Area width
game
area width minus
subject the one which you are causing it
and here after that we'll be performing
the calculation by saying
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similar way we would like to use for my
right coordinate also
now math or round DOT number give area
Game Area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
solve it let me give some space
divided by Circuit
okay so that's where exactly it's got
closed
okay now here our application is now
ready by calling the function called
create four like that we'll be going to
create another function called create
game area let me go and create all the
functions first so we are saying
function create game area
create game
area this is another function for me
after this create Game Area there will
be another function I'm going to create
it that is called control
function control
okay after that we'll go the right one
more function called function
write score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call write score
there's another function which you're
going to write it down here that is
called function
write score is done now we say create
Square so create
square is another function and finally
we'll have a call change direction
function
change
Direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it here in our system
well
we know it very well that we have taken
this called create food create food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
create game area we are defining two
locations of our X Direction and Y
interactions we said
snake
x equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we say dot X
for the X Direction
y equal to
snake position we are taking once again
zero
and Dot okay so two directions we have
taken X Direction and Y Direction
now here we are starting
gain
area context Dot
filter unit variable it is a property 12
style equal to which color you want to
fill this up
so I'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values I'm saying
0 comma zero comma Game Area width
game area with comma
again area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take this game area
context again
Dot stock Style
stroke Style
equal to now we give the another color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
frame Gateway context dot stroke react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
0 comma zero comma Game Area width
cool
cover again
area
height
so we are passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions now see the when
you talk about snake game it move left
right and Center up and down so now in
this case we have to increment the
situations accordingly so we say if
the snake Direction
if the snake Direction
to
right
then we say snake
X
Plus
now
else if
same let's copy this
snake Direction
left
then what should happen here we say
snake
X
minus minus
[Music]
okay so we are taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're talking about left right we
sit down
so in this case we say snake
why
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
then we say this name
y minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this lcf condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say if snake X
snakes X
minus 1
or
sneak X
double equal to
Game Area width which we have taken
divided by
solve it
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus 1
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
foreign
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah I will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created it sometime back and inside is
control
it will take some parameters so what
else parameters we can pass okay we can
say
X
comma
snake y
third parameter will be
mistake
so this would be my another function
okay so here we are passing the
conditions just like that
okay now here
this is available in this parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not described more so we're
writing the right score the score will
be written here and here is a clear
interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay I'm using game start
Dot
disabled equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it so this is the logic for we
have written to this particular example
now we can use another if more
conditions here just to check the
behavior of my code if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well here we have finished till this
equal to false and we returned now going
forward after this return We would like
to have another condition for the snake
X so we say if
snake eggs
with snake X double equal to
snake food
dot X
okay let's make food cortex I am
positive time perfect
why
double equal to
snakes
food dot y
then in this case I will say VAR new
head
or new head sorry
new hit equal to here
X colon
snake X
y colon snake y
snake X and Y column
a snake why these options we are taking
it
now after that we are using this option
called play score
plus equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition
we are saying VAR
new head
equal to
snake
dot or
okay and we are saying new head
dot X
equal to snake X
and new head
dot y equal to
snake why
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
Dot unshift
and shift
snake Dot and shift and here we are
causing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for Loop by saying for
VAR equal to 1 I
equal to 0
then I is less than
sneak Dot
length
and
snake dot length and once I
plus plus
okay later on we just use the optional
call
create
square and in the screen Square we are
crossing
snake
snake position
I
Dot
X
comma same
snake
dot y
that's it so it's getting closed here
and after that we are calling the same
option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than using this we can
say snake foot.x
and it's like foot.y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now we start working with
your control
control needs to take three parameters x
y and the array so we are passing this
option called control and in this
control we are taking X
comma y comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
VAR I equal to 0
I is listed
array Dot
length and I plus plus and after that
we'll be using this option called if
condition and here we say
array
I which value we are causing dot X
double equal to
X
Ampersand ampersand
here we say array
with a position called I
and in this we are saying dot Y and this
position we are checking for
the Y condition
for the Y condition so it Returns what
true
written
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return what
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option you call write score this
right score we have to use the game area
context
area context Dot
font
equal to here we'll be passing the
situation we are saying 50 pixels
50 pixels and then
sense iPhone
self
after that we're using called a media
context again let me copy this
take it again called Game Area context
Dot
fifth style equal to here I'll be using
the another color now so we say hash
okay now after that we are saying once
again the game area context Dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say Plus
player score whatever it is with Game
Area width
Game Area width
slash two
minus
100. and then again
area width
slash two so this is where exactly the
right score where the data will be
actually written
okay next will be having this option
called create square and this great
Square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about column X second is taking
Y and now here we are using this game
major context
same
Dot
film style equal to let me give the
color
after this we are using call same query
and text game media text Dot
fill react here we are saying X
multiplied by
solve it comma y
multiply by
solve it comma
solve it
this is what my create square is now we
are left with only one option that is
known for change direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters now here we are passing this
option called War keys
equal to e Dot
and later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
40.
okay
am percent ampersand
disconnect
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake Direction equal to
so we are changing the directions here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elseif
y four times
all right
okay
so here we took this 30 40 and here we
say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 27.
29 38 37 and here we say up let's change
to what
left
down
right
here we say
up
left
so three options we have changed and
last but not least here I will just use
window Dot
on key down equal to
change directions
and
window
dot on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay so in this initialize we are having
this game start dot on clicking and all
so you have a call start game now so
just start game will be calling it here
okay so start
we have a call snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling this
function called what create food
clear interval and here we say driver
equal to here set clear interval and
here
change
game area
slash
speed size
let's say you want to use it okay
everyone so our code is almost ready so
we have this complete JavaScript code
ready with me now it's time to basically
use within my HTML just to check how it
may behave so in my HTML page I have
written this uh normal speed number
game speed value button start we will
call game start after that we have a
call canvas where we click ID code to
call Game Area depth classical to
relative and
that's it and here we have a call script
Sr secret to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if I try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay I really do not see any changes in
my code
okay despite I'm having this because the
CSS content is actually missing
okay because they're only my code really
look better because if there is no CSS
it won't really make good towards my
application
okay and I also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
little later on let me go back and try
to bring CSS into this picture now so
first of all
have this index.html file with me and
here I want to use CSS so inside my head
tag we want to use
link Ariel
equal to
style sheet
okay Enter
equal to
app
dot CSS
okay now here
in my CSS we want to offer certain
details what those details I want to
start working with I will start with my
body part
body
so we want to offer the font family
so
foreign family maybe a little bit later
on I can use it first I want to use
margin
margin 20 pixels
Auto
later text
align
Center
next font size
font size 150 pixels also 150 percent
and here we want to say background
background image since I do not have an
image so I will just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise you have to say
URL
and insert this URL
to give some values but I leave it as a
blank because I do not have any image I
will say background color
in this background color I can just use
white
after that height
I can just say 800 pixels
after that background position
background position I want to use Center
then background repeat
background repeat I want no repeat
then background size
four
okay let's see if there is an effect in
my
okay I see it's now in the middle
better now inputs canvas we have to
basically take that here we should talk
about called input
foreign
font size
font size may be optional I can make it
but let me say font size 100
percent
then text align
Center
then padding
I want to say 5 pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that I can use canvas
in this canvas I want to see the
background color
I just say white
after that border radius
Auto radius I can say 20 pixels
then
Shadow if I want to use it so I just say
box shadow
box Shadow I can say three pixels
5 pixels
on 6 pixels
and the color is
let's check
awesome so I can see here uh
the logic is there so Shadow you can
easily see how it is been using
and that's it and this div
I can say div Dot
relative
okay position
absolute
top
here I'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly a program now
when I said start
okay so there may be some error here
okay
that they cannot set a property or call
on click
null so this we can just check this into
this
game start dot on click
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a while
but anyways we have our created CSS and
now going forward we'll be implementing
rest of the logic within my code okay
everyone so we have changed some names
here because there was some value was
mismatched so we have basically changed
those values with your properties and
now when I try to relaunch my
application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html5 when I try to
add
so it's just as usual same let me say
start and here you can see game start
when I go up you see like it's starting
right now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier okay we can just
change the direction go up and you can
see the score Channel being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value called
what zero by default set
whatever value you want to take if it is
start now you can see based on that the
speed can be justified and the example
can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
fine so like that you can see that
automatically this will be position this
one is called food that is how we have
used it by example now called app.js you
can see we are using this example name
called food create food you can create
food of the specific and travel time
this will be automatically created and
the snake will eat and increase the size
of the code
okay that's it and now the CSS has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first scheme which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 Plus
hours of video content for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
excuse let's get started with the
JavaScript interview questions
so let's get started with a beginner
JavaScript questions we have a multiple
levels available here we start with a
beginner level first so the first
question is always like what do you
understand about a JavaScript so we know
it very well the JavaScript is a very
very popular scripting language it is
basically designed for client-side
scripting and server side scripting
development
why server side because nowadays
JavaScript is also used in a backend
using node.js so that's why it is also
called for server side development so
the question is like
JavaScript is
actually also helps the developers to
develop some more responsive HTML pages
okay which can be well understood and
executed by the web browser okay which
having the support capabilities for
object oriented programming skills
now the next question is like what is
the difference between a JavaScript and
Java see the reason because the
JavaScript initials are Java so
everybody think like okay there is some
relationship with the Java so actually
the thing is like there is no
relationship with Java I would say
JavaScript is object based language
whether Java is object oriented language
lot of syntax and some standards are
matching with Java that's why exactly it
is saying it is Javascript
otherwise there is nothing like that but
another difference if I talk about
JavaScript is mainly designed to run
with the browsers whether Java is
designed especially for the virtual
machine and operating system
another thing is like JavaScript does
not need a compilation because it is
directly used interpreter but when you
talk about called Java it requires a
compiler as well as The Interpreter both
no now what type of various data types
are supported so all standard data type
second byte short ink long float double
character Boolean these all different
type of data types are supported in
JavaScript also just like in traditional
programming languages
okay
now what are the features of JavaScript
so the first feature which you always
remember it's it is a lightweight
programming language it is been
interpreted by the browsers rather than
compiled
it is a cross platform that means it can
work across multiple browsers so it is
not specific to the browsers
so that we need to understand next it is
open source hence you do not need to pay
for any licensing fees it comes free
with all different type of browsers it
is an object oriented but I would not
set as a pure object oriented I would
rather say it is an object based
language
next it can gel well with multiple front
end as well as the backend Technologies
because most of the languages which are
coming up in a market they have a
support available to get integrated with
the JavaScript and due to that
JavaScript is very very popular
so it is also used especially for the
development like a network based
application so in case if you want to
have some kind of network Centric
application here the JavaScript really
suits very very well
okay next question what are the
advantages of JavaScript so the first
Advantage which we are talking about
like JavaScript basically have a very
very nice interactive language it is a
event based okay functional programming
language I would say so it is a quick
feedback because it loads very very fast
in your existing web pages it is
giving you the support of developing a
very very rich user interface because of
that your application look consistent
across multiple type of browsers
another is like we have a call variety
of JavaScript based Frameworks are
available or you can talk about angular
you talk about react you talk about Vue
they're all basically different type of
JavaScript based Frameworks that helps a
developer to enhance their skills with
writing less amount of codes
so how you create a script or how you
create a object in JavaScript it is very
simple the curly braces curly braces is
basically designed to give you the fee
of this is a typical object there are a
variety of ways are there to create an
object in JavaScript which we're gonna
see in our next Web video
okay now here we see about the next set
of questions which are there with us
like how to create a array in JavaScript
so creating an arrays in JavaScript is
very very easy now you can see the
square brackets okay they are the way to
basically create a array in a JavaScript
so just a square brackets are a very
very simpler way so called allele
literals to create
the array objects in JavaScript actually
you should know that array is also
object which is a predefined object
comes with your JavaScript so called
implicit options
now what are the built-in methods
available in JavaScript so you remember
about these methods comes from those
built-in objects comes with your
JavaScript as we have mentioned in our
last slides like math Boolean string
okay date they're all basically
predefined objects are available under
those objects these methods are actually
available like date as you can see it
will display the current date and time
concat to concat two different type of
string push some
adding some new records into your array
pop to remove round to do the round
length to calculate the length of the
string so these are all some well-known
methods or frequently used methods
available in JavaScript
now what different type of Scopes
available in JavaScript for the
variables now so
Scopes are basically designed to give
you the visibility
within your program okay so different
type of Scopes are available when it's
called a global scope so Global scope is
having the availability within a file
anywhere else you can access this
particular code or particular variable
this is called Global scope and local
Scopes are those Scopes which are
accessible within a function
and hence cannot be accessed by any
other function or outside of this
function so two standard type of Scopes
which are available here
now what is this keyword in JavaScript
this means to refer the current object
okay so whenever you see that this
keyword it is designed to refer the
current object in JavaScript so we
typically Define that this keyword to
assign the value to my current object
properties usually this is a place where
that this keyword is mostly used
now what are the conventions of
giving the names to the variables okay
so some standard naming convention which
we should always follow
but few things as you remember there are
certain result keywords are there in
JavaScript which you cannot offer while
giving the names to your variables or to
your functions
like if I can say or let cons and many
more which are there available which you
cannot assign to your unexisting
variable provided or functions under
your JavaScript
now
here they are trying to say variable
names cannot begin with any numeric
value like you cannot give VAR with ABC
so not ABC I would say rather One Two
Three or something like that so there
must be a combination of I would say
integer as well as a character
okay so they must only begin with letter
or underscore characters it is the same
like as we have it in Java also
now naming conventions are very very
important JavaScript is a case sensitive
hence the small a in capital E have two
different meanings for the JavaScript so
that part needs to be well taken care of
now what is the Callback in JavaScript
so you need to understand the Callback
in JavaScript is a kind of function
which you are passing as in parameter to
the other function to execute
okay so callbacks are mainly designed to
tell your application that they need to
wait rather than continue to execute
so callbacks will help you to behave
asynchronously and that's what exactly
this is most valuable feature of
JavaScript
so as I discussed already so it is where
the function needs to be passed to get
executed
so how do you debug a JavaScript code so
to debug your JavaScript code in any
browser you can just press the F1 no
matter which browser you have it either
Chrome or Firefox or anyone you can just
press the actual key and there you can
get this option called debugger where
you can just go and perform all the
necessary debugging related stuff right
over there or so many other editors like
in Sublime Text Visual Studio code atom
they're all offering you the built-in
support to debug your JavaScript code
now what is the difference between a
function declaration and function
expression so this is a very very simple
difference so when you say function ABC
here okay so you declare as a separate
statement within the same JavaScript
code
okay in another example what you do you
define a function within a variable name
called a which you can create to
construct some another object for this
that's the only difference between these
two
so this function can be called before
the function is defined and this will be
created where the function is pointing
and reaching it
okay so it can be used only after that
so that's what we have discussed now
going forward this offers the better
code readability and better code
organization and that the other part is
basically used to create a conditional
or a declaration functions
so what are the ways of adding the
JavaScript code in an HTML file so they
are
I would say two ways are available one
either you can declare it in a separate
file you can add it or second you can
write a embedded JavaScript code where
you can just write a JavaScript code
either in your head tag or body tag but
there will be one difference like if
you're writing it as an embedded
JavaScript you cannot use it for the
different HTML file where the internal
JavaScript file will be limited to that
HTML however external Javascript would
be more useful when you want to reuse it
again and again
so these were some standard basic
JavaScript questions for us so let's go
ahead and talk about something which is
related to your intermediate questions
in JavaScript
now so what you understood about the
cookies see the cookies are basically a
kind of a small text file okay which is
kept in your browser and contains
information about your client activities
okay so whenever the client is accessing
your websites these websites can track
your activities through this particular
cookies okay so this just basically
record your general behaviors like what
you're doing with your website so that
accordingly they can give you the better
recommendations
now how are you going to create a cookie
in your JavaScript so creating a cookie
cookie is one of the property available
under your document object so that you
can create it using document.cookie and
give a key so your all Cookie are stands
with your key and value pair so you have
a key you have value pair so how are you
going to read the cookie
so cookie you can read with the help of
the same property called documented
cookie and here you can just use this
statement
like what key in value pair so whatever
the keys you have defined similar queue
will be reading it to give the value of
whatever option you want to read it
now how are you going to delete the
cookie so cookie can be deleted it very
easily by calling this delete cookie
function where you can just tell about
the time and duration when you want the
cookie to be get deleted
so when you set the expiry time so
cookies are deleted after specific
period of time that will be treated as a
good programming practice
so what is the difference between a
letter and VAR keyword see there's a new
feature which is there added called net
keyword which is known it's called Block
Level scope the blockable scope means
your variable whichever you're defining
under any Block Level statement will be
limited to that particular block like if
you're defining it any opening block and
closing block so beyond that you cannot
see that suppose if you're defining it
under this block or any block so these
type of variables are no longer
accessible outside where the VAR keyword
will be typically treated as a global
variable and hence it can be accessed
anywhere
so what is the closure in JavaScript so
closure is basically gonna give you a
better way of providing the consistent
way of developing a JavaScript code for
the developer so closets are basically
created whenever a variable that is
defined outside of this current scope
can be accessed within the current scope
okay that means which is a variable
which is defined outside of the scope
even using the scope of this particular
closure it can be accessed inside too
now what are the arrow functions in
JavaScript
friends Arrow function in JavaScript is
very very popular now they're just gonna
give you a kind of alternative way of
defining the function keyword these are
just a shortcut way of
defining the function in
JavaScript these are simple handy
functions I would say
so what are the different ways of HTML
can be accessed in JavaScript course so
there are multiple ways are there so you
can access using document.getelement by
class name you can access get element by
ID you can get access document get
element by tag name and you can say
document.query selected so these are the
multiple options are aware through which
you can access the element
within your HTML tags
what are the ways of defining a variable
so our keyword as we discussed you can
define a variable you can also Define
the variable using const so if you
define any variable using const so these
variables will get constantly declared
and it cannot be changed once you define
the value so any value or any variable
which is defined using const it cannot
be changed in later switches
what are Imports and export in
JavaScript so to make your JavaScript
modular
so this is an option available of
importing and exporting it
so what exactly the difference
difference is very simple like you are
writing the set of JavaScript code and
if you want to get it accessed outside
in another Javascript file so how the
two JavaScript files can communicate
with each other that is very exactly the
important export code comes to make your
JavaScript highly reused and more
modular
now these are the quick example as you
can see now two different files are
there so if you want to make your
particular variable
or function accessed outside you always
use export keyword with them and if you
want to access them out we can just use
an import keyword as you can see it is
defined there
so another file can easily access your
the content of the previous files to
make your code even more modular and
useful
so what is the difference between a
document and window in JavaScript see
document is the one which is the part of
your document part which user can
actually see that
okay so the document object is the
object which falls under the category of
window window is a top level object so
in JavaScript we have option available
name call bom that is called browser
object model in which the top level
object which is there that is called
window and under this we have a called
document so whatever you see under your
browser it is the part of your document
so what are the sum JavaScript
Frameworks and their uses the JavaScript
Frameworks are mainly useful to make
your application more organized with
less code and without getting into into
the detail okay so having this
particular framework will give you the
opportunity so that developer can use
the JavaScript in much more better way
to write a complex code in more
simplified manner this is where exactly
your Frameworks are designed for so
there are some very prominent and useful
Frameworks I can react angular viewages
and lot many other names are there in
Market which will be using the
JavaScript as a core and take the entire
JavaScript development to the next level
so the next question is what is the
difference between
a undefined and undeclaring JavaScript
see it is very simple undefined means
the variable which is undefined you're
declaring a variable
okay and which you haven't defined okay
that means the variable has been
declared but the value has not yet
assigned that is called undefined
Undeclared means the variable which
you're trying to access that itself is
not available it doesn't even exist
so what is the difference between
undefined and null in JavaScript see
undefined as I already told you it means
the variable has been declared but it is
not assigned with any value null is
actually the assignment value that we
can assign to any variable which contain
no values as an alternative I would say
so what is the difference between
session storage and local storage see it
is very simple HTML5 has offered these
features to you
so the session storage and local storage
both offers you the data which can be
stored in a browser but session storage
is short-lived the moment your page is
deleted or closed the session data is
immediately deleted whether local
storage data is remained for the longer
period of time and the data doesn't get
deleted after the browser history is
over
okay so I would say the local storage
time span is far bigger compared to the
session storage okay everyone so we'll
have some Advanced JavaScript questions
now we've already seen the beginner
level as well as the intermediate level
questions now it's time to discuss about
some Advanced double questions too like
the first questions like comes like how
do you empty an array in JavaScript so
it is very simple if you want to assign
so there are a few ways of that number
one by signing the array length toward
to the zero so automatically turns to
empty second is what by assigning the
completely empty array
Okay the third will be by popping up all
the elements of the array
so multiple options are there and the
last which you talk about called by
using the splice function so these are
the four important aspects are there
which you can treat how to empty your
JavaScript array in a very very
simplified manner now what is the
difference between event capturing and
event bubbling see this is one of the
very very common question we talk about
even capturing even capturing is
actually the kind of process where you
just try to
capture the event of most outermost
element and then propagating it to the
innermost element
so even capturing is what like you're
talking about picking up the element or
picking up the event from the outermost
like you talk about called nested div
tags so you pick up the particular you
know even from the most outermost div
tag and you're just passing it to the
innermost then it's called capturing the
bubbling is the process okay which
starts with the innermost and goes to
the outermost element is just an
opposite direction that is called event
bubbling
so the case question is one of the very
very popular like what are the strict
mode in JavaScript see the strict mode
of JavaScript is introduced to give the
more better error handling capacity of
the JavaScript so whenever we talk about
call strict mode so all variables have
to be declared explicitly so you cannot
leave it like that and it cannot be
assigned to the read-only properties
so we can enable the strict mode only by
adding the use stick mode on the top of
the Javascript file
now what about
and how we would be able to get the
following output of the below JavaScript
code so we have a call y equal to 10 and
we have written one function in the if
block and after that we just capturing
the value of a and then you are printing
the value in a console.log so what would
be the output output for that see it
will be a call then undefined
once again it will be kind of what it'll
be
undefined how commit would be look it is
very simple first thing
okay in your application
you are basically saying the if
condition statement in the code will
evaluate the eval function
as you know it very well what exactly
the evaluation is later on the eval
function
okay will take the function and return
the function ABC whatever the function
it is available and then inside the if
statement it execute the ABC and returns
undefined because as you know it
variable the if statement code executed
runtime while the statement inside this
if condition is being evaluated so
that's where exactly it is next can you
write a JavaScript code for adding the
new element in a dynamic manner is
exactly you can write it down so you
have this very common function available
name for document.createelement like
people say like I want to add the new
text boxes when I click on the button
so
I can write it very well so either it
will be a text box or it will be the new
element you want to add it so
document.createelement is one very very
common
I would say the function and later on
you can use the typical Dom
functions like I can talk about the
create next node or append child so
using this combination you can easily do
so
next what is the difference between call
and apply very common question so the
call method whatever the method you have
it in a call these method arguments are
provided individually okay along with
the this value but in apply what happens
arguments are provided in the form of
array along with this value that is the
only difference between column apply
so what would be the output of the below
JavaScript code as you can see right now
we've written one object name called
student provided one property called
college with ABC after reducing object
dot create passing this is student as an
object itself and after that using
delete
student1.collision console.log
student.com so what would be the value
for this
is very simple it is very simple example
of object orientation so the output will
be what ABC as we are accessing the
property of student object so certainly
the value will be what ABC for sure now
what would be the output for below
JavaScript code as you can see now we
have written a one
function 4 and it is written 11 so using
type of Foo so this will certainly refer
to what to the error reason is why
because of function definition can have
only single reference variable as its
name that's why exactly it will be
throwing what an error to you how do you
remove the duplicate value from the
JavaScript array it is very simple we
have a call filter function so the
filter method I can basically call it
and three arguments it may be expecting
it the name of the array the current
element and the index of the current
element so that it can remove all the
duplicate elements from there so how do
you remove the duplicate elements from
JavaScript array so it is same way I
told you like first it takes three
parameters so using the filter method
and by using the for Loop so the empty
array is used for sorting all the
repeating elements so like that you can
simply make it more easy
so how can you draw a simple JavaScript
Dom so you can say it is a very simple
JavaScript Dom Elements which are there
where you can have the document and then
the HTML and followed by all child
elements like an head tag body tag body
may contain further child elements like
an anchor tag
so these are all basically known is
called a presentational elements through
which this complete HTML hierarchy will
contain inside this now with that we
have come to an end of the JavaScript
tutorial and also to the software
development week by simply yarn we hope
all the sessions were informative and
interesting
if you have missed out on any of our
sessions then please feel free to check
out our official YouTube channel the
link to which is in the description box
below if you have any queries regarding
any of the topics covered in the section
or the previous sessions then please
feel free to write us down in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to Resort all your
queries until next time thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
to stay tuned for more from Simply learn